Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Hast du mitbekommen? Die Telekom gibt Deutschland in Sachen Digitalisierung eine 5.
Von 100.
Ja hier ist der schwarze Kanal, da du es nicht kanntest, dachte ich mir überrasche
ich dich mal mit einem ganz anderen Intro, so fing das nämlich immer an,
das kannst du nicht machen, warum?
Man muss unerwartete Dinge tun, das ist wichtig, jetzt bist du total überrannt,
ich hab dir nicht Bescheid gesagt, ich hab dich nicht mal gewarnt,
jetzt kommt jetzt gleich noch Sendungsgäst Jan Fleischhauer oder so was.
Boah, sowas kannst du ja nicht mit mir machen ey.
Geht's dir dann schlecht oder was? Naja ich meine so leitet man halt die richtige
Propaganda ein, so klingt das dann ne.
Mit unseren vergeblichen Versuchen hier die Netzpolitik irgendwie positiv wohin zu führen.
Da musst du richtig schön knallhart hier die Methoden des Propagandaministeriums
übernehmen. Da fängt er schon mal mit einem guten Intro an.
Also da bin ich ja mal gespannt auf die Kommentare.
Warum?
Die Leute wissen jetzt überhaupt nicht in welchem Podcast sie sind.
Wir können ja auch nochmal das richtige Intro spielen.
Ich bitte darum.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 473 vom, was haben wir denn heute? 26. Oktober 2023.
Und ich hab Lilos schön auf den linken Fuß erwischt das Freund.
Aber jetzt kann ich wieder, jetzt kann ich podcasten.
Jetzt bist du drin, wenn die Musik stimmt, dann können wir da voll loslegen.
Tim Höttges, ich kannte das nicht, du hast den Link jetzt in den Schaum.
Tim Höttges hat Deutschland eine 5 gegeben. Er meint Schulnote 5.
Also quasi.
Und was ich sehr schön finde ist, also Tim Höttges ist der CEO der Deutschen
Telekom, er gibt Deutschland in Sachen Digitalisierung eine Note 5.
Im EU-weiten Vergleich hinke Deutschland hinterher. Das hat er richtig festgestellt.
Nur einen Bereich nimmt er von seiner Kritik aus.
Und du denkst halt so, wahrscheinlich die Netze.
Und der Witz ist halt zu lame, um den jetzt irgendwie zu twittern.
Und dann scrollst du halt runter. Den Netzen gibt Höttges gute Noten,
der Telekom noch bessere.
Das kommt sehr überraschend, ich hätte mir jetzt gefragt, naja,
achso und er rechnet mit einem Tal der Tränen, ja, wo rechnet er denn mit einem Tal der Tränen?
Da kann er mich abholen, da sitze ich schon seit ein paar Jahren.
Ich kann dir sagen wo das ist.
Der kleine Internetnutzer möchte gerne aus dem Tal der Tränen abgeholt werden.
Wie lange muss ich noch warten bis alles gut ist? Jetzt bieten sie bei mir in
der Straße Glasfaser an.
Oh echt? Ja Glasfaser und jetzt hier Telekom und so sei dabei und so.
Ich klicke so online, so mal gucken. Okay, was habt ihr denn da?
Also erstmal Zeitauskunft, ja Ende 24.
Super, alles klar, deswegen muss ich jetzt hier irgendwie, die schicken ja wirklich
Drückerkolonnen durch die Häuser, völlig nervige Menschen, total anstrengende, wirklich so.
So wie wir, die den ganzen Tag nur von Glasfaser reden, Tim, also ganz ehrlich,
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass du die jetzt nervig findest,
seit ungefähr zwei Jahrzehnten textest du alle voll mit Glasfaser und jetzt
kommen sie und du bist gemein oder was? Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Also erstmal, naja, also ich hab ja überhaupt gar kein Problem,
wenn da irgendwie normale Telekom Mitarbeiter auftauchen.
Ich stell mir so vor, guten Tag Herr Pretlaff, wir möchten mit Ihnen über Glasfaser
reden. Ich auch, kommen Sie mal rein.
Setzen Sie sich, lenen Sie Keks.
Du lauerst denen doch auf, du guckst doch am Türspiel und man sieht endlich, komm.
Das Ding ist, Glasfaser ist jetzt sagen wir mal nur ein Codewort,
das versucht einem ja irgendwas zu versprechen, nur dann guckst du halt mal drauf,
was denn das dahinter steckt und dann ist es so, ja wir haben jetzt irgendwie,
lassen ihnen jetzt die Anschlusskosten fürs Haus, ja klar, weil sonst setzt
sich das ja auch nie durch und dann habe ich genau dieselbe Geschwindigkeit wie vorher auch.
Das heißt sie bieten mir nach wie vor diesen asymmetrischen Klemmbadge an mit
250 Megabit und irgendwie bisschen weniger hoch,
wo ich mir halt nur denke so, ja okay gut das hab ich jetzt auch schon über
DSL und außerdem wenn schon brauch ich auch mal ne Aussage was für ein Glasfaser
also wohin, also ins Haus oder in die Wohnung oder was wovon reden wir jetzt.
Und außerdem ist das auch preislich alles nicht so attraktiv.
Aber Hauptproblem ist, man kriegt da nicht einfach mal einen Gigabit.
Doch, du kriegst ein Gig down und ein fünftel Gig ab.
War also zumindest bei mir in der Straße nicht von die Rede oder habe ich irgendwas übersehen?
Also angeboten wird 1000 down 200 ab für 80 Euro im Monat.
200?
So. Recht. Dann kannst du geschäftlich, gucken was für Geschäftskundentarife,
wenn, wird ehrlich sein, da stehen dann einfach nur die Nettopreise und sind
fünf Euro weniger oder sowas, aber.
Das Hauptproblem ist ja auch, wir müssen uns ja nicht über Tarifhunde halten,
Hauptproblem ist, die haben halt irgendwelche Leute geschickt,
die einem wirklich noch auf der Tür, die dann so, ja kann ich bei ihnen mal
reinkommen und mal gucken und so weiter.
Wahrscheinlich einer.
Da war ich kurz davor die Polizei zu rufen, weil das so diese typischen Tricks sind.
Hier ist einer der sagt er ist von der Telekom der will rein.
Enkeltrick, Enkeltrick.
Naja du lachst aber das sind hier nur mal die Methoden im Prenzlauer Berg,
also hier kommen Leute ran und erzählen dir irgendeine Scheiße von Glasfaser
nur um einmal durch deine Wohnung laufen zu dürfen.
Nur um dir den Eindruck zu vermitteln, dass.
Nein um zu gucken was man da klauen kann.
Wenn die sagen wir bringen Glasfaser, dann denkst du natürlich,
oh guter Mann, bitte bleib hier, komm rein. Ja ja, nee natürlich.
Das ist der Enkeltrick beim Hackersilberrücken.
Wir bringen Glasfaser.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, aber mit mir war da nichts zu machen.
Auf jeden Fall Note 5 für Deutschland, das ist also wirklich eine sehr optimistische Sicht der Dinge,
also ich glaube, ich gebe Herrn Höttges noch insofern halbwegs recht,
Ja als das jetzt die netze an sich jetzt nicht unbedingt das kernproblem sind.
Da gibt es zwar auch eine menge zu meckern ja also da würde ich dann auch sagen wir mal da ist dann.
Das ist eigentlich eine 5 ok, aber der Rest ist halt 6.
Das ist genau, das ist völlig ok, wenn er sagt hier, pass auf Deutschland 6, Netze 5.
Germany one point.
Aber es ist auch nicht jetzt primär seine Schuld.
Auch, aber das Problem ist ja ein gesamtgesellschaftliches,
weil wir einfach als Gesamtgesellschaft nicht verstanden haben was wir eigentlich
haben wollen und was wir eigentlich zertifizieren wollen und dementsprechend
macht es die Politik nicht und die Gesellschaft führt auch nicht die Leute mal auf die richtige Spur.
So die ganzen vergleiche die angezogen werden sind
einfach falsch und es halt einfach es geht nicht voran
und ja und man muss man muss schon
sagen dass tim hüttges jetzt in diesem bereich natürlich informiert ist international
informiert ist und grundsätzlich erstmal in der lage ist auch hier eine eine
schulnot zu erteilen und da halt man muss ihm auch punkte dafür geben dass er.
In seinem Optimismus und in seiner Strahlkraft hier eine positive Note gibt,
ja, mit Potenzial, die noch ein bisschen Potenzial beinhaltet,
die nicht so vernichtend ist, wie die Note, die man eigentlich verdient hat.
Insofern kann man dem Mann hier nix vorwerfen. Und dass er sein eigenes Produkt
natürlich dann noch besser darstellen muss, entstammt seiner Rolle.
Insofern alles gut. Er hat ja, er ist halt ein Optimist.
Er sagt, wir kriegen eine 5 und vor uns steht ein Tal der Tränen.
Das ist ein hoffnungsloser Optimist. Und so einen brauchen wir auch.
Ja, den brauchen wir, wenn wir in diesem Land noch was werden wollen.
Insofern, danke für den Input. Ja, natürlich.
Ja, was willst du denn sonst dazu sagen?
Ich bleibe bei meiner ursprünglichen Einschätzung, wann das Problem überwunden wird.
Und du weißt ja, wann es so weit ist.
Was auch in dem Artikel steht, in den USA wurden bei der deutschen Telekom-Tochter
T-Mobile derweil zuletzt 5000 Stellen gestrichen.
Sie sollen von künstlicher Intelligenz ersetzt werden.
Ne unter anderem von Kürzlich-Herz-Tickets, da kommen wir gleich noch zu.
Das meinte er also mit all der Tränen, ich schmeiß euch alle raus.
So zu Beginn eine schöne Nachricht, weil ich hatte ein bisschen Langeweile und
dann kam irgendwie Chat-GPT und meinte so ey hier komm,
im selben Dialog kannst du jetzt hier auch Bilder machen und ich hab's ja eigentlich
gar nicht so mit Bildern.
Aber dann habe ich mal so ein bisschen meine Prompttechniken geflext.
Ja und hast du gut gemacht.
Und hab mal so ein paar Bilder erzeugen lassen, da habe ich schon länger so
den Glauben gehabt, dass wir da hinkommen.
Ich weiß noch, wann haben wir angefangen? Von einem Jahr ungefähr muss es gewesen sein?
Da hast du deine ersten, mit Stable Diffusion, und da hatten wir noch so die
Phase mit irgendwie sechs Finger an der Hand und irgendwie alles sah noch so
ein bisschen aus wie aus einem Horror-Movie.
Und dafür war es Open Source und bei mir selber berechnet.
Alles in Ordnung, aber ich wollte nur darauf hinaus, dass mittlerweile dann
diese Technologie doch binnen Jahresfrist so einen krassen Sprung nach vorne
gemacht hat und auch da werden wir noch drüber reden.
Auf jeden Fall kann jetzt sogar so ein Vogel wie ich so Bilder erzeugen, die korrekt aussehen.
Ich hab kürzlich auch, um im Rahmen eines Vortrags nochmal so ein bisschen das nachzuzeichnen,
hab ich dann endlich, das hab ich vorher nie benutzt, mit Journey,
dieses irgendwie über Discord und dann muss er chatten, ey was für ein Interface,
aber er hat sofort gesagt, ok nehmt mein Geld, ich will weitermachen.
Das ist ein wirkliches Rabbit Hole, was du da reinschreibst und es ist auch
wirklich krass dir einfach nur anzugucken.
Kannst du mal den Prozess kurz anreißen weil ich hab das selber nie so hundertprozentig verstanden.
Du musst in irgendeinen Discord Kanal und dann
irgendwie 85 mal klicken dann hast du bezahlt oder so keine Ahnung und dann
gibt es irgendwie in diesem Discord Kanal gibt es dann Gruppen die heißen Noobies
und da schicken die dich dann erstmal hin ja und in diesen Noobies Gruppen bist
du eigentlich in einer halbwegs sortierten Gruppe mit irgendwie,
Warte, ich mach das jetzt mal ganz kurz. Willst du ein paar Leuten drin?
Und dann ist das so ein bisschen wie IC, dieses Discord.
Also du musst dann irgendwie in diesem Fall sagen slash imagine.
Damit sprichst du den Mid-Journey-Bot an, wenn du in so einem Kanal bist,
wo der jetzt ist. Ja, was eben in diesen Nubi-Kanälen so ist.
Und dann sagst du Discord Update, meine Güte. So Mid-Journey.
Das sieht eigentlich aus wie Microsoft Teams. Du bist jetzt hier in so unterschiedlichen Tenants.
Und jetzt bin ich hier in dem Mid-Journey-Tenant und sag, alles klar,
hier Nubi-Room hast du nicht gesehen.
Raute Nubis heißt der, wie halt früher auch schön im IRC.
Und da ist jetzt zum Beispiel einer gerade die ganze Zeit dabei,
der will offenbar Monster machen. Der will Monster malen. Und der schickt jetzt
halt einen prompt an diesen Mid-Journey-Bot nach dem anderen,
und dann malt er den Monster.
Der will jetzt hier in blau aus. Und dann in der Antwort kriegst du dann vier
Bilder erst mal. Und dann hast du zwei Möglichkeiten, Upscale und Vary.
Ja, also eins, zwei, drei, vier. Und dann hast du U1, also Upscale,
dann kriegst du das Bild in größere Auflösung.
Oder Vary und dann sagst du ihm halt so, das ist schon in die richtige Richtung,
variier das mal bitte weiter.
Und ja, sowas, was natürlich auch nochmal superflashig ist, ist,
dass da Leute halt in allen möglichen Sprachen die Proms reingießen, ne?
Weil das Ding ja außerdem noch alle Sprachen kann.
Und was sehr schön ist bei Midjourney, während dieser Bot da so bastelt,
zeigt der dir die Phasen, wie das Bild entsteht.
Also irgendwie so 15 Prozent, 46 Prozent.
Und dann schärft sich so dieses Bild vor dir. Also es ist schon ganz geil. Ja.
Und was mir aber auch aufgefallen ist, weil jetzt gibt's ja das große Thema
Prompt Engineer. Wer ist Prompt Engineer?
Also wer kann am besten Prompts schreiben für diese Dinger, wo dann die geilsten
Bilder dabei rauskommen.
Und meine Skills sind da eingeschränkt. Also da kommt häufig,
sag ich mal, zeig das Bild nicht unbedingt das, was ich haben wollte.
Ich habe zum Beispiel gesagt, mal mal bitte eine Katze, mal mal bitte ein neuronales
Netz, was gerade lernt, wie eine Katze aussieht.
Und dann habe ich aber eine Katze mit einem neuronalen Netz drin bekommen.
Sieht geil aus, aber ist halt nicht das, was ich wollte. Und was ich...
Habe ich auch runtergeladen.
Einhörner sind hier beliebt. Und was ich aber dann irgendwann gemerkt habe,
wenn du guckst, wie die Leute die Prompts schreiben, und das ist auch völlig klar.
Der ursprüngliche Lerndatensatz für diese Dinger ist ja das Internet und das,
wie dort Bilder beschrieben werden.
Und viele Bilder im Internet werden einfach überhaupt nicht beschrieben.
Einige werden beschrieben. Und die werden entweder beschrieben,
weil sich Menschen über das Old-Tech darüber Gedanken machen, über Accessibility.
Aber du weißt auch genau, wofür die meisten Bilder beschrieben werden oder von
wem die meisten Bilder beschrieben werden im Internet.
Von den SEO Spackos. Von den Leuten, die für Search Engine Optimization zuständig sind.
Und wenn du einfach möglichst viele Wörter aneinander reißt,
dann kriegst du halt das Bild. Und das ist mir irgendwie aufgefallen.
Irgendwie so, was ist das denn hier? Zum Beispiel,
also natürlich geht das noch weiter,
also Midjourney ist inzwischen besser, da kannst du dann auch irgendwelche Leute,
die Extremely Detailed Image, Athens in 250 BC, Image from above,
Houses, Roads, Temples, White Marble, UHD, 64K, dann können die jetzt irgendwann
16 zu 9 angeben und solche Sachen.
Aber Änne scheinen, wenn du jetzt einfach Komma getrennt Bildinhalte wieder
gibst, dann sind die da am ehesten drin.
Und ich erkläre mir das damit, dass das im Prinzip, wer hätte das gedacht,
man hat eigentlich gedacht so okay.
Mit mit mit mit dieser Gen AI sind jetzt endlich diese ganzen Google Fütterer
arbeitslos, aber die sprechen halt die Sprache von denen haben diese Gen AI
gelernt und die werden jetzt Prompt Engineer.
Ich sagte ja PVC Fitting Klebemuffe Rohrverbinder Rohrschlauch Klebefitting
zum Verkleben Qualität aus Europa.
So hast du das mal malen lassen? Ja ne?
Das ist in der Tat eins wo ich zu kämpfen hatte.
Oh, das widerspricht ja jetzt an meiner These.
Also ich bin an Midjourney ein bisschen vorbeigeschrammt, mir war das ein bisschen zu viel,
ich weiß nicht, irgendwie hat mich das nicht so mitgezogen und erst so richtig
in den Sog bin ich jetzt gekommen,
nachdem bei JetJPT das DOLL I3 innerhalb von JetJPT freigeschaltet wurde und
wenn man da sozusagen für bezahlt was ich tue, dann war das quasi damit drin.
Dann dachte ich so okay alles klar damit kann ich jetzt irgendwie umgehen,
mach das jetzt einfach mal. Es war mehr so ein nochmal den Zeh nochmal tiefer
ins Wasser rein mal gucken ob das Wasser mittlerweile, die Temperatur das letzte
Mal war es mir einfach zu kalt.
Und ja, dann hab ich ein paar Tipps auch,
die ich so in letzter Zeit schon aufgelesen habe,
aus verschiedenen AI Newslettern und es gibt ja auch auf den Chatkanälen der
Welt gibt es ja auch mittlerweile eine Menge Leute, die da interessante Tipps
geben, ja und dann hab ich da so einen Pfad gewählt, der tatsächlich ganz gut war.
Und angefangen habe ich, da möchtest du wahrscheinlich jetzt mal drauf schauen
mit dem Bild für die letzte Freakshow.
Das dürfte dir sehr gut gefallen. Da brauchst du nochmal kurz die Webseite aufrufen.
Die Sendung hieß Computer im Regen und...
Ja gut, das ist natürlich einfach.
Ne das ist gar nicht so einfach.
Weil wenn ich jetzt sage mach mir mal einen Mainframe Computer im Regen,
also im Regen gar kein Problem.
Aber die Computer sahen alle aus wie so 80er Jahre, Homecomputer,
Apple 2, Atari, weißte Keyboard mit CRT Bildschirm.
Und weil einfach die Wahrnehmung, also selbst wenn ich sage alter Computer,
das ist ja heutzutage so zu sagen, so und Mainframe ist natürlich auch sehr schwierig.
Und dann kam sowas bei raus. Und mit der Methode war ich schon mal sehr erfolgreich.
Also gerade wenn man etwas well-known reproduzieren möchte, würde ich den Weg nehmen.
Bei den anderen Sachen, dann hab ich halt irgendwann auch mit Logbuch angefangen,
hab mal so für die letzten, weiß gar nicht, zehn Sendungen oder so,
einfach mal angefangen Bilder zu erzeugen.
Das war auch ganz interessant. Das ging teilweise ganz gut, teilweise war es schwierig.
Also manche Sachen waren wirklich sehr einfach und manche Sachen waren extrem schwierig.
Zum Beispiel an diesem Wodka Red Bull, bis ich da irgendwie...
Das ist aber ein super Bild! Das ist ja ein Hammer Bild!
Ja, das ist super, aber das waren dann auch wirklich 5, 6, 7,
8 Anläufe, die ich gebraucht habe.
Ah, dann musst du das schon nochmal selber, ja. Pass auf, aber mach mal deinen
Signet kurz auf. Ich hab dir nämlich PVC-Fitting Klebemuffe,
PVC-U-Muffe, Rohrverbinder, Rohrschlauchklebefitting zum Verkleben Qualität
aus Europa mal von Midgerty malen lassen.
Hast du gesehen? Siehst du? Oh, nicht schlecht!
Verstehst du jetzt warum ich glaube, dass ich da on to something bin?
Das ist halt einfach ein PVC-Fitting Klebemuffel,
PVC-U-Muffel, Rohrverbinderrohrschlauch Klebemuffel zum Verkleben Qualität aus Europa,
das ist es einfach und ich hab direkt vier, so und jetzt kann ich nämlich,
so jetzt kann ich sagen ich möchte, die dritte ist ganz gut,
sollen wir die dritte abscallen oder nochmal Varianten machen?
Ich weiß ja nicht worauf du jetzt hinaus willst.
Na dein Qualität aus Europa Bild ist ja nicht so gut, ich finde ja hier,
ich möchte ein paar Variationen von der 3.
Kannst du es dann auch gleich in 16 zu 9 machen, kannst du das auch sagen?
Ja da gibt's irgendwie Leute die machen das.
Naja um das vielleicht kurz zu Ende zu bringen, ich hab dann auf jeden Fall
so ein bisschen rumexperimentiert und dann irgendwann tief in der Nacht aufgehört,
nachdem ich einige Ergebnisse hatte und ja also das funktioniert ganz gut und
vor allem ist es ja eine perfekte Paarung die Kultur lustige Podcast Titel zu wählen.
Und diese AI-Sache zusammen. Weil als es dann nämlich auf so Sachen ging wie
Generationsflüchtling, da kommst du jetzt mit SEO nicht weit.
Ja, da hast du aber auch ein sehr schönes Bild gemacht.
Ja, und wie bin ich da hingekommen? Da hab ich folgende Methode gewählt.
Da hab ich ja wirklich explizit gesagt, ich möchte gerne den Begriff Generationsflüchtling.
Das hab ich genau geschrieben, warte mal. Kannste ja auch nochmal abrufen hier.
Ich hab im Prinzip immer so ein ähnliches Konzept gemacht.
Also ich möchte gerne mit Dali 3 ein Bild erzeugen, das möglichst abstrakt den
Begriff Generationsflüchtling erklärt und hab dann noch ein bisschen was dazu geschrieben,
so was für mich so die Aspekte sind, sodass man so ein bisschen sich irgendwie
in seiner eigenen Generation nicht so wohl fühlt und mehr so den anderen zu,
der anderen Generation zugehörig fühlt und so weiter, insbesondere im Hinblick
auf Technologie, das war dann schon mal ein Fehler.
Dann kam dann halt so diese klassischen, ja alter Mann sitzt an der Bushaltestelle
und benutzt irgendwie eine VR Brille und sein Smartphone alles gleichzeitig,
während daneben noch irgendwie auf Papier notiert wird und so weiter.
Das war mir dann irgendwie zu Stereotyp.
Und dann musste ich dann halt auch noch so ein bisschen selber Kreativität reinbringen
und das ist halt eher so ein bisschen abstrakt malen zu lassen.
Also man muss da schon in so einen kreativen Prozess reingehen, gar keine Frage.
Und das merken wir uns vielleicht auch gleich nochmal für die Diskussion des Themas.
Ich werde aber bestimmt jetzt nicht für alle Sendungen Bilder machen.
Also falls ihr da draußen im Prompt Engineering auch gut unterwegs seid,
könnt ihr euch gerne mal befleißigen.
Bevorzugt hätte ich allerdings Vorschläge in 16 zu 9 Format.
Ich hab jetzt ein paar Quadrate gemacht.
16 zu 9 hier ich
habe jetzt vier varianten moment ja live on air hier vier varianten das ist
also tatsächlich habe ich pvc fitting klebemuffer pvc umuffer rohrverbänder
rohrstoch klebe fitting super kleben qualität aus europa minus minus a r 16
zu 9 ok linus aber dir ist schon aufgefallen dass ich für die sendung schon
ein bild habe Ja, aber das ist nicht gut.
Du hast gerade gesagt, wenn man ein besseres machen will, kann.
Und ich hab jetzt ein besseres. Okay, ich sag dir mal, was die Probleme da waren.
Also ich wollte eigentlich etwas haben, was so ein bisschen aussieht wie so
ein Gütesiegel, was man auf so eine Produktpackung mit drauf klebt.
Also einfach so ein this book will change your life Sticker als Qualität aus Europa,
da war das Problem, dass Dolly ganz schlecht ist mit Text,
also du sagst halt schreib das drauf aber das steht dann da nicht drauf und so weiter,
also so Text konkret, das klappt manchmal und manchmal klappt es überhaupt nicht
und am besten kommt man weg, weg mit dem Text mach was anderes,
mach irgendwie ne europäische Karte drauf, nimm Sterne und so weiter. Und...
Irgendwie bin ich dann versandet und das was da jetzt klebt,
also dieses, ich find das eigentlich ganz hübsch so mit dem Europa und den Blümchen
und so weiter, also das ist ganz nett. Es sagt halt Qualität aus Europa.
So heißt ja die Sendung, die heißt ja nicht Klebemuffe, die heißt ja Qualität
aus Europa und das muss ja zum Ausdruck gebracht werden, finde ich.
Also mit der Klebemuffe alleine kommst du jetzt hier nicht voran.
Da muss schon Europa auch.
Qualität muss da drin sein. Deswegen hab ich gedacht Gütesiegel.
Naja und so weiter. Also man muss sich da ein bisschen was einfallen lassen.
Ich nehme dankend Prompts oder fertig gerenderte Bilder entgegen.
Mal gucken wenn sich da viele engagieren wollen müssen wir vielleicht noch ein
Dokument aufmachen, das koordiniert bekommen aber mal schauen.
Vielleicht bin ich auch der einzige der sich dieses Themas ernsthaft annimmt.
Also Twitter ist weg und die Leute jammern nicht mehr so viel.
Die hängen den ganzen Tag auf Dolly und mit Journey Rom und lassen sich irgendwas malen.
Wir machen mal einen Link in die Shownotes.
Aber ich hab dir auf jeden Fall jetzt schon mal einfach die Lösung zur PVC-Fitting-Klebemuffe,
PVC-U-Muffe, Rohrverbinder-Schlauchklebefitting, Zum Verkleben Qualität aus
Europa habe ich die jetzt schon mal geschickt. Da bin ich mir ganz sicher.
Da ist auch Europa mit drin.
Ja mit gelb und blau und das ist, ja das ist das.
Das sehe ich jetzt noch nicht so ganz die Qualität. Also ich sehe Schläuche
und Muffen und Fittinger.
Und haben die keine Qualität aus Europa?
Wo ist da der europäische Aspekt bitte?
Gelb blau, gelb blau überall gelb blau.
Naja da ist auch rot.
Ja dann sag, dann gibts in deinem Chat die Bitte und sag du willst das rote, gelb, blau haben.
Ja aber gelb, blau ist Ukraine, nicht Europa. Also das ist goldene Sterne, Sterne, Sterne.
Also du siehst schon, es ist alles ein bisschen aufwendiger,
aber ich bin mir sicher wir werden das noch vorantreiben.
Mal gucken was wir für einen schönen Titel für diese Sendung finden.
Diese Sendung geht dann auf jeden Fall auch mit einem hübschen 16 zu 9 Bild drauf.
Ne, dieser Sendungstitel ist Enkeltrick beim Hacker Silberrunden.
Das wissen wir noch nicht. Ich weiß das schon. Ja das weißt du, was weißt du denn schon?
Das wird am Ende demokratisch entschieden bei uns. So sieht's aus.
Red du mal weiter, nächstes Thema, ich lass schon mal hier ein Episodenbild malen.
Nimm mir doch nicht meinen Job weg. Immer musst du alles besser machen.
So, okay, soviel zum Housekeeping. Feedback? Ja, wir hatten einiges Feedback,
ich greif mal nur ein paar Sachen raus. Und zwar zum Moodle One Hack schreibt SM Langer.
Also ich glaube ihr habt den guten Herrn Dieter Müller völlig falsch verstanden.
Für mich hat er sich eindeutig dafür ausgebrochen, dass der Staat endlich Unternehmen
für Sicherheitsvorfälle gegenüber ihren betroffenen Kunden direkt haftbar machen sollte.
Denn damit würde der Staat ganz klar seiner Hoheitsaufgabe gerecht werden sicherzustellen,
dass das Schutzniveau gegen Cyberangriffe steigt. Stimmt. Schöne Anmerkung,
lassen das mal so stehen.
Und zu deiner Feststellung, das ist sicher bei dem, wie hieß das Auto noch gleich, was du da?
Der Pontiac Aztek, ich fand den ja gar nicht so schlimm, um ehrlich zu sein.
Auf jeden Fall haben sowohl Blubb als auch Stefan wesentlich in den selben Kommentar abgesetzt.
Ich vermische mal beide zu einem. Rein zur Thematik hässlicher Autos,
die einem nicht aus dem Kopf gehen, empfehle ich Linus eine Suche nach Fiat Multipla.
An sich gar kein so schlechtes Fahrzeug, aber optisch sehr speziell. Und das stimmt.
Der Fiat Multipla, ja, für den hat Michael Schumacher geworben.
Ist das nicht dein Ernst?
Doch klar.
Echt?
Ja. Und dann hat er nämlich in der Werbung drei Stühle nebeneinander gesetzt,
weil der Fiat Multipla hatte drei Sitz vorne.
Der hast du vorne zu dritt gesetzt.
Ach so.
Keine Sau weiß warum, aber als ich einmal zu dritt im Fiat Multipla gefahren
bin, war das auf jeden Fall witzig.
Muss keiner hinten sitzen. Ja, aber es geht halt bis drei.
Aber da ist wirklich die Ästhetik, als die Ästhetik da eingezogen ist,
hat irgendjemand hinten nochmal
eine Tür aufgemacht und dann ist es gleich wieder raus aus der Halle.
Das hat leider nicht funktioniert. Das stimmt, das ist wirklich,
also da ist dieser Aztec ja wirklich geil dagegen.
Also dieser Multipla geht überhaupt nicht. Ehrlich gesagt, Fiat Multipla sieht
aus, als wäre das so aus Mid-Journey rausgefallen, aber du hast irgendwie noch
nicht die richtigen SEO-Begriffe benutzt.
Welches Modell guckst du denn jetzt?
Achso, ich habe gerade einen gefunden, aber das war ein April-Scherz von Autobuild,
ich habe nämlich jetzt einen modernen gesehen, ich dachte, die hätten sich ernsthaft
nochmal dazu herabgelassen, den nochmal neu aufzusetzen.
Fiat will den Multipler neu auflegen, diese Schlagzeile ist am Video und Artikel
war der Autobild April Scherz.
Ja das nimmt dir echt keiner ab.
Aber schon mal gut oder? Aber haben sie auch gut gemacht, also wer auch immer den da gerendert hat.
Weißt du was ich meine? Der sieht wirklich aus wie so ein KI-Unfall.
Als hätte man so ein Auto in das andere so reingesteckt und irgendwie die falsche
Anzahl von Scheinwerfern und so,
also sogar der Rückspiegel sieht komisch aus, also ich bin ja ein großer Freund praktischer Autos.
Da ist der Multipla was für dich? Und die Sache ist doch, pass auf,
es ist ganz einfach, ich muss so viel Multipla sitzen.
Nicht ohne Liebe, also da muss schon auch der Gestaltung.
Das siehst du doch nicht, wenn du da drin bist. Ist doch egal. Du sitzt doch da drin.
Ich spüre das mit geschlossenen Augen.
Du sitzt mit drei Leuten da vorne und lachst wie Schrott, die anderen gucken.
Du spürst einfach die Blicke.
Na gut, soviel dazu. Dann gibt es eine Ankündigung für die Jahresendveranstaltung, den 37.
Chaos Communication Kongress, haben wir schon angekündigt, aka 37.
Chaos Communication Kongress, 37c3 sagen wir.
Sagen wir, ja.
Seit dem 16 c3 sagen wir das übrigens.
Ist der Tom draufgekommen. Vorher war es einfach der 15. Chaos Communication Kongress.
Und mit dem 16. C3, da saß ich mit Tom irgendwie zusammen und wir grübelten
die ganze Zeit nach einem Motto und uns fiel ums verrecken nichts ein und dann
gab es so einen Moment der Stille und dann drehte er auf einmal seinen Laptop
oder Computerbildschirm,
ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, was es damals war, zu mir.
Damals konnte man Computerbildschirme nicht einfach drehen.
Doch, ich hatte so ein iMac G4 und wie geil, den konnte man noch nicht drehen.
Klar, das war der auf diesem Teleskop, den konntest du super drehen. Ach der? Die Lampe.
Der Lampen.
Ja, der Lampen iMac, ganz großartiger Computer. Aber ich glaube,
welches Jahr war denn das? 1999, da hatten wir schon Laptops.
Also ich glaube es war ein Laptop, ist ja auch vollkommen egal,
auf jeden Fall zeigte er mir diesen Entwurf.
Und da stand einfach nur 16 c3 drauf und das war so ein freeze moment das war
so ein ja wir wissen in dieser mikrosekunde sofort das wird das ist es und das
hat auch Potenzial zu bleiben und was ist wir kündigen den 37 c3 an.
So, aber den haben wir ja eigentlich schon angekündigt.
Was es jetzt gibt ist der Call for, was heißt denn das P in diesem Jahr?
Participation.
Willst du da was zu sagen?
Ja es gibt einen, also auf dem,
Call for Proposals kann man das ja auch nennen,
also es gibt ja bei dem Kongress Vorträge und diese Vorträge werden von unterschiedlichen
Teams kuratiert, die sich,
einem Track zugehörig fühlen, also einem thematischen Bereich,
und in einem Content-Team zusammen sich organisieren.
Zum Beispiel zu klären, wie viele Slots haben wir für jeden Track.
Ist hier vielleicht eine Einreichung, die potenziell in einem anderen Track
ist? Was man so an Austausch vielleicht untereinander braucht?
Fragen für einen. Es gibt dann auch noch den Track CCC, wo einige Vorträge dann
drin landen können und so weiter und so fort.
Und der CFP ruft quasi dazu auf, Einreichungen zu machen. Der CFP geht bis zum
11. November, 23.59 Uhr ist Einreichungsende. Bis zum 3.
Dezember gibt es dann die Benachrichtigung über angenommene Vorträge.
Und vom 27. bis 30. Dezember findet der 37.
Chaos Communication Congress statt. Die Tracks, also die Themenbereiche,
die da behandelt werden in alphabetischer Reihenfolge, sind Art & Beauty.
Da geht es also um den Bereich, du kannst mit einem Computer Kunst und Schönheit schaffen.
Alles, was also im künstlerischen Bereich ist. Zum Beispiel,
wenn Tim und ich hier mal einfach ein bisschen Dolly mit Journey,
da haben wir bestimmt keine Chance, dort angenommen zu werden.
Dann gibt es den Bereich Ethics, Politics und Society, der also die gesellschaftlichen,
ethischen und politischen Aspekte im weitesten Sinne von Technik und Digitalisierung behandelt.
Da wären dann vielleicht so was wie Vorträge
zum Thema Chatkontrolle oder KI-Regulierung oder sonstigen Dingen.
Willkommen. Außerdem ist das informelle Track-Motto dieses Jahr Resignation ist langweilig.
Es geht also immer um zukunftsweisende, optimistisch stimmende Ideen und Berichte.
Muss auch nicht unbedingt alles irgendwie Netzpolitik oder IT sein.
Aktivismus im weitesten Sinne ist da auch gerne gesehen.
Dann gibt es den Track Hardware, der sich mit dem kreativen Umgang und der Entwicklung
von Objekten auseinandersetzt, allem, was einen physischen Eindruck hinterlässt.
Schöpfen, Textilien, Musikinstrumente, Roboter, was auch immer ihr baut.
Flug- und Weltraumfluggeräte.
Allerdings Elon Musk rechne ich da jetzt keine großen Chancen aus,
dass er angenommen wird, aber ihr versteht's. Dann gibt's den Track Science,
wo es sich im weitesten oder im völlig klaren Sinne um wissenschaftliche Einreichungen handelt.
Forschungszentren, Universitäten, irgendwas Geiles, was Wissenschaft schafft
und interessant ist, ist da willkommen.
Im Track Security geht es also um IT Security.
Natürlich traditionell einer der großen Tracks, also mit vielen Themen und vielen
Einreichungen beim Hacker Kongress.
Der andere sehr große Track ist PolSoc, also Ethics, Politics and Society,
in dem ich übrigens üblicherweise immer mitgeholfen habe bei der Auswahl des
Programms, so die letzten zehn Jahre oder so.
Und dieses Jahr bin ich eben im Bereich Security.
Wollte mal was anderes machen.
Also geht es natürlich um Netzwerke, Betriebssystem, Web, Speicher,
Fehlverwaltung, Krypto.
Am schönsten natürlich einfach Dinge, wo irgendwas kaputt gemacht wurde und
dann repariert wurde. Der Reparierenteil ist ja immer der Wichtige.
Und dann haben wir häufig so...
Sag mal, nicht notwendigerweise dauerhafte Tracks. Ja, wir hatten ja zum Beispiel
mal Philosophie als Motto, wo wir uns immer noch mal einen weiteren Themen Schwerpunkt setzen.
Und den gibt es dieses Jahr in Sustainability and Climate Justice.
Das sind natürlich Bereiche, die im Prinzip ja in Science oder in Polsok genauso
gern gesehen und willkommen sind.
Aber um quasi zu sagen, hier, wir haben für diese Themen ein eigenes Stück Kuchen
im Programmbereich vorgesehen, gibt es dann natürlich noch diesen Track.
Also alles, was alle die Ideen zur Bekämpfung der sozial-ökologischen Krise vorstellen möchten.
Klimakrise und Gerechtigkeit, Lösungen für eine nachhaltige und gerechte Welt
entwickeln, da möchten wir in dem Track Einreichung haben. Ja,
und ich glaube, damit habe ich jetzt auch wirklich alles gesagt,
dass wir freuen uns auf Einreichungen.
Vor allem auf qualitativ hochwertige Einreichungen.
Also der CCC freut sich. Also wir freuen uns vielleicht auch.
Hinter jedem dieser Track gibt es dann ein eigenes Team, was diese Auswahl trifft.
Der CCC freut sich. Ich bin ja ein Mitglied eines Teams. Ich freue mich da auch
drauf. Aber ja, am Ende wahrscheinlich auch die Besucherinnen und Besucher der Veranstaltung.
Ja, ich bin in keinem Team, aber ich freue mich auch, wenn ihr das macht.
Sogar der Tim freut sich.
Muss immer nur klar machen, was wir ist, ne?
So, macht ordentliche Einreichungen. Und bitte, was ich sehr wichtig finde bei
Einreichungen ist, wir benutzen ein etwas in die Jahre gekommenes System,
du kennst es Tim, den FRAP.
Es wäre sehr wichtig bei eurer Einreichung so als Tipp, wenn ihr so ein bisschen
vielleicht klar macht, so Worum geht's hier?
Warum ist das wichtig? Warum ist dieser Vortrag besonders? Ja,
oder zum Beispiel, warum bin vielleicht genau ich diejenige Person?
Oder welches Wissen habe ich als Person, was mich jetzt ausgerechnet zu diesem Thema qualifiziert?
Die Vorträge werden betrachtet, ohne Berücksichtigung der Personen,
also wir gucken auf die Inhalte, das heißt, wir werden jetzt auch nicht jede Person googeln,
das heißt, wenn ihr, was weiß ich, Forschungsdirektorin bei einem Biotech-Unternehmen seid,
könnt ihr das ruhig noch mit erwähnen, damit wir wissen,
dass das mit der Impfung gegen Krebs dann jetzt wirklich euer Durchbruch ist
und ihr nicht aus irgendeiner ESO-Bude kommt.
Also bewerbt da euren Vortrag. Ihr habt eine harte Konkurrenz und es ist schön,
wenn ihr den Vortrag den Leuten schmackhaft macht, weil wir je nach Trackteam
mussten da halt, weiß ich nicht, ein paar hundert Einreichungen angeschaut werden
und das geschieht natürlich auch mit einer notwendigen Geschwindigkeit.
Also werbt für eure Vorträge. Alright. Wo reichst du ein, Tim?
Ich hatte nicht vor irgendwas einzureichen.
Ich hab vor was einzureichen, aber das ist auch genau das Problem,
dass ich eigentlich gerne was in Security eingereicht hätte,
was jetzt irgendwie schwierig wird.
Nein, auch dafür haben wir natürlich Lösungen, wenn Leute, die auch im Track
Team oder Content Team sind, einreichen, dann müssen die den Raum verlassen.
Und dann sind sie natürlich aufgrund der Bekanntschaft mit dem Team einer noch
größeren, einer noch schwereren Kritik und Bewertung ausgesetzt als normale Einrechner.
Ja, ich habe nichts zu erzählen.
Du erzählst ja auch den ganzen Tag. Du hast ja irgendwie weiß ich wie viele
Podcasts. Ich habe gesehen über Logbuch Netzpolitik hast du jetzt so einen Werbebanner,
so einen Bannertausch Ding gemacht.
Da kann man mal sehen was du den ganzen Tag erzählst. Wundert mich ja nicht,
dass du nichts mehr zu erzählen hast.
CRE, Freakshow, Logbuch, Netzpolitik, Raumzeit, UKW,
Forschergeist, pausierte Podcast, archivierte Podcast, Serien-Podcaster bist du.
Ja gut, aber ich meine da, also Vorträge, ich halte gerne Vorträge,
aber ich halte gerne Vorträge, also generell.
Ich möchte mich eigentlich immer nur dann mit irgendetwas zu Wort melden,
wenn ich da auch was beizutragen habe.
Möchtest du jetzt sagen, das wäre nicht der Fall bei mir?
Nein, das wollte ich damit nicht sagen. Ich wollte nur erklären,
warum ich nicht vorhabe,
irgendwas einzureichen, weil ich derzeit gar kein Thema habe,
wo ich wie nennenswert Erkenntnisse gesammelt hätte, die es sich speziell auch
in der Community des Kongresses zu teilen lohnen würde.
Dieser Maßstab ehrt dich Tim. Dieser Maßstab ehrt dich.
Ja als jemand der jetzt lange genug Content gemacht hat, kann ich sagen dieser
Maßstab ehrt dich. Also dich ja erstmal zu fragen ob du was interessantes zu
erzählen hast und dann ob du auf die Bühne des CCC Kongress muss,
das ehrt dich. Das ist mein Leitmotiv.
Ich hab Leute die machen das andersrum. Wenn man nix beizutragen hat,
einfach mal die Fresse halten.
Ey nicht die da nur zitieren.
Ich weiß nicht wen ich da zitiert habe, aber das ist jetzt auf jeden Fall nicht falsch.
Ja das könnte der Dieter Nusich auch mal zu Herzen nehmen. Wahrscheinlich.
Ne ich denke das ist sogar eine, ist auch glaube ich so eine,
wie nennt man das, so eine Lebenserfahrung.
Man möchte ja gerne, wenn man sich äußert, möchte man ja auch gerne,
dass die Leute einen wahrnehmen.
Es gibt ja so Dampfplauderer, die legen keinen großen Wert da drauf.
Ich hab nur den Eindruck, als ob sie keinen großen Wert darauf legen,
ob sie überhaupt noch wahrgenommen werden. Hauptsache sie reden,
hauptsache sie drücken, ja in der U-Bahn, aber nicht nur in der U-Bahn,
das hab ich schon überall erlebt.
Oder deine Glasfaserhändler.
Naja du weißt schon was ich meine. Leute die einfach die ganze Zeit so den Drang
haben Leute mit irgendwelchen Informationen oder auch nur Worten einzuregnen,
aber den entscheidenden Fehler machen, das Ding ist ja, man will ja eigentlich
am Ende, also alle heischen ja nach Anerkennung.
Man will ja geliebt werden, man will Anerkennung haben und man möchte gerne
relevant sein, man möchte gerne irgendwie eine Bedeutung in seiner Peergroup
erlangen dadurch, dass man irgendetwas interessantes tut.
Und manche reden aber auch einfach nur und machen dabei, selbst wenn sie was
zu teilen haben, was wirklich interessant wäre, oft den Fehler,
dass sie es einfach hoffnungslos übertreiben und das Schlimmste ist, sie hören nicht zu.
Weil das ist wirklich ein entscheidender Punkt bei der ganzen Kommunikation,
wenn man gehört werden möchte, wenn man verstanden werden möchte und wenn man
vielleicht auch eine gewisse Anerkennung bekommen möchte,
dann ist es sehr, sehr gut erstmal in Zeit zu investieren,
anderen Leuten zuzuhören, weil wenn andere Leute merken,
dass ihnen zugehört wird, dann A, bemerken sie das,
B, finden sie das auch gut und C, sind dann auch bereit einem selbst zuzuhören
wenn man denn dann dran ist so und da das richtige Timing zu finden ist sicherlich
nicht immer einfach aber ist auf jeden fall ein guter Ansatz.
Und deswegen sollen die Leute erstmal Logonetzpartikulieren.
Deine Schlussfolgerung, meine Kernerkenntnisse, mein Leben, ich kann ja auch
nicht so viel aber das habe ich verstanden.
Und das ist auch super gut und es ist es ist finde ich auch tatsächlich gerade
erfreulich dass wir so ein bisschen darüber reden weil das sind ja,
Das ist ja ein schmaler Grad mit dem CCC-Kongress. Das ist eine,
international wahrgenommene Veranstaltung mit entsprechender kleiner Anzahl
an sehr einflussreichen Vorträgen.
Und wir möchten natürlich auch einerseits das bewahren.
Wir möchten, dass viele geile High-Quality-Vorträge da eingereicht werden.
Oder Groundbreaking. Wir möchten aber natürlich genauso, dass unsere Community zur Sprache kommt.
Dass zum Beispiel gute Vorträge gehalten werden.
Man kann ja auch einen guten Vortrag halten, der nicht, was weiß ich,
Tagesschau-Seite 1 ist oder so. Tagesschau hat gar keine. Tagesschau Meldung 1 ist.
Und in dieser Ansprache finde ich das immer sehr schwer, weil man einerseits
natürlich auch, man möchte ein paar Leute wirklich, ich bin ganz ehrlich, wegschicken.
Von denen will man keine Vorträge haben. Man will auch keine Einreichung von denen haben,
weil die sich auf den Kongress bewerben, weil sie vielleicht irgendein Produkt
bewerben wollen oder sowas,
weil sie irgendwie einfach Irgendeinen Quatsch einrechnen oder es gibt auch Leute,
die reichen dann so sechs Vorträge ein, das ist vorsichtig gesagt so,
wenn du da sechs Vorträge einreichst, musst du dir die Frage gefallen lassen,
ob das denn, wie das denn sein kann, dass du ausgerechnet zu sechs Themen jetzt
ausgerechnet die beste Speakerin bist, ne.
Da bin ich halt irgendwie, bin ich so ein bisschen fröhlicher,
wenn jemand einen Vortrag einreicht und denkt mir, okay, super,
damit hat sich diese Person jetzt ein Jahr befasst und das möchte sie jetzt hier wieder geben, ne?
Sowas gibt's ja alles, aber ich finde es genauso schwer, Leute zu entmutigen,
diese Einreichungen zu machen, wie Leute übermäßig zu ermutigen,
weil beides führt zu einem schlechteren Programm, ne?
Also wenn wir, oder zu mehr Arbeit zumindest, wenn jetzt irgendwie viele Leute mit,
die nix zu sagen haben, sagen, ach geil, da kann ich ja auch mal einreichen,
dann wirst du potenziell mit weniger relevanten Dingen überflutet,
triffst eventuell schlechtere Entscheidungen und wenn du jetzt irgendwie sagst,
reicht nicht ein, reicht nicht ein, dann passiert dir das nämlich sehr sehr
schnell, dass du Menschen, die vielleicht wirklich was cooles zu erzählen haben,
aber vielleicht ein bisschen Stagefright haben, Lampenfieber haben oder.
Selber das gar nicht für so toll halten was sie machen.
Das gar nicht für so toll halten was sie da machen, weil das machen sie ja nur,
also so toll kann das ja nicht sein, weil machen sie ja.
Und deswegen finde ich das sehr schwer darüber zu sprechen, deswegen sage ich
so, bitte, bitte, bitte bringt einfach gar keinen Scheiß mit und der Rest ist egal.
Ja. Naja, müsst ihr selber wissen.
Und zugehört habt ihr uns ja jetzt genug und jetzt seid ihr dran.
Ja da passiert was. Da passiert was.
Es ist ja ein Krimi den wir hier beobachten. Es ist der Krimi um das Internet.
Und weiterhin ist das Ding im Rat. Der Rat hat seine Abstimmung ja jetzt schon zweimal verschoben.
Wir haben ja auch schon gesagt, die Mitgliedstaaten sind gespalten,
Deutschland soll dagegen sein, Spanien dafür und jetzt müssen die irgendwie
gucken und jetzt kommen die da
alle und machen wir jetzt was und dann hier Hütchentrick, dann Abstimmung.
Und jetzt fällt aus dem Ausschuss für bürgerliche Freiheiten,
dem Liebe-Ausschuss, wo das ja alles diskutiert wird, gerade so ein Kompromissvorschlag raus, ja.
Und der sieht so aus, es darf überhaupt nur noch bei begründetem Verdacht ein
Scanning von Kommunikationsinhalten stattfinden und begründeter Verdacht darf
sich eben beziehen auf eine Person oder eine Gruppe,
aber nicht auf alle Nutzenden.
Wir haben ja im ursprünglichen Chat-Kontroller-Ansatz so eine Idee,
wenn die Plattform geeignet ist, dass da viel Material getauscht wird,
dann kann das für die Plattform angeordnet werden und dann sind alle betroffen.
Das soll nach diesem Vorschlag nicht mehr sein. Das heißt, diese Technologie,
die ihr haben wollt, ist klar, was auch immer für eine Bilderkennung und Scanning,
nur bei begründetem Verdacht bei Personen oder Gruppen. Gruppen.
Ja, zum Beispiel irgendwelche faschistischen Polizisten oder so.
Aber das wäre jetzt nur so ein Vorschlag, wenn man das mal ausweiten möchte.
Also es muss eine benannte Person oder Personengruppe sein. Dann ein kompletter
Ausschluss von Scanning von Ende zu Ende verschlüsselter Kommunikation.
Also damit auch kein Kleinst-Side-Scanning. Wenn du jetzt irgendwie Three-Mile-Signal
Alles was Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt ist, bleibt unangetastet.
Und dann gab es ja noch andere Aspekte in dieser Chat-Kontrolle-Gesetzgebung,
die immer so ein bisschen hinten rausfallen in der Diskussion über Client-Side-Scanning.
Es soll keine verpflichtende Alt-Cast-Kontrolle mehr geben, außer bei Pornoseiten
und Computerspielen, die Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten bieten.
Gehen wir erst mal darauf ein,
wo, also die, wenn du ein Computerspiel-Kommunikationsmöglichkeit hast,
dann sollen da Hilfemöglichkeiten angeboten werden,
wenn du irgendwie Betroffene bist, also du bist da in dem Spiel,
irgendwie ist was komisch, Kommunikationsmöglichkeit, dann gibt's da irgendwie,
dann soll dir weitergeholfen werden, ist ja gar keine so schlechte Idee,
dass man die potenziellen Kinder damit nicht alleine lässt oder so.
Und bei Pornoseiten, die müssen Altersverifizierung machen, müssen aber sowieso.
Und die sollen automatisiert erkennen, wenn Nutzende nach Missbrauchsmaterial suchen.
Und dort ist eben die Altersverifikation verpflichtend.
Jetzt kommt aber der Punkt, bei der Altersverifikation, da ist ja jetzt die
Frage, wie machen wir die denn?
Da wurde ja auch die ganze Zeit drüber diskutiert, weil, was ich mir habe erzählen lassen ist,
Wenn man auf diese Pornoseiten geht, Tim, ich weiß nicht, kennst du wahrscheinlich
auch nicht so, aber dann soll, so wird mir berichtet, dann steht da im Prinzip
so, bist du 18, dann kannst du Ja drücken und dann war das jetzt die Alterskontrolle.
Da gibt es jetzt Leute, die klicken, die klicken da potenziell vielleicht drauf,
dabei sind die gar nicht 18. Was? Ja.
Die machen falsche Angaben im Internet.
Die machen falsche Angaben. Und das machen insbesondere, und das wird dich jetzt
auch schockieren, Leute unter 18.
Die dürfen gar nicht auf die Seiten.
Aber die gehen da trotzdem rein?
Die gehen da trotzdem rein.
Indem die einfach auf den falschen Button klicken oder was?
Hättest du das immer früher gewusst? Das ist der kleine Tipp im Usenet.
Gibt so Tricks ey, da schaut man nicht drauf.
Ja, die Kinder, die sind mit allen Wassern gewaschen. Absolut.
Das ist die Digital Natives. Da zeigt sich das dann.
Einfach mal mit so einer Hacker-Mentality, ne? Einfach mal alle Knopfe drücken
und gucken, was passiert.
Und so, jetzt ist halt die Frage, wie machen wir die Altersverifikation?
Da soll aber jetzt gesagt werden, die Daten dürfen über den Verifizierungsprozess
hinaus nicht gespeichert werden.
Es müssen anonyme Accounts zugelassen werden und man darf keine biometrischen
Daten für den Verifizierungsprozess verlangen.
Das ist ja dieses auch wirklich völlig absurde,
also völlig absurde Vorstellung, die da einige vertreten haben,
für die es ja auch eine technische Lösung gibt, dass dann die Kamera angeht
und dann irgendein biometrischer Test gemacht wird, ob jetzt da am anderen Ende
jemand über oder unter 18 Jahre alt ist, was natürlich auch...
Das kann ich dir doch jetzt schon sagen. Also die Software, die habe ich dir
doch jetzt schon geschrieben, wo ein KI-Filter dich erstmal so à la Face 10
Jahre älter macht und dir dann wieder ein Webcam-Device bereitstellt,
was dein Browser sagt. Ja, das bin ich.
Und wenn du dann sagen musst, guck mal nach rechts oder nach links,
damit das Ding irgendeine Biometrie-Scans macht, das Ding ist doch in 5 Minuten gebaut.
Aber okay, viel schlimmer ist natürlich die Idee, Menschen da biometrisch zu
erfassen, um ihr Alter zu... Also das war eh Unsinn und deswegen steht hier drin, das gibt's nicht.
Jetzt ist aber der Punkt, der das einzige mir zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt bekannte
Verfahren, das eine anonyme Alterskontrolle ermöglicht.
Also nicht die Daten rausgibt und gleichzeitig aber tatsächlich das Alter. Ist eh ID.
Hat halt ne super scheiß User Experience, weil du musst irgendwie deinen Ausweis
mindestens an ein NFC-Gerät halten,
was jetzt so vielleicht bei dem Besuch von Pornoseiten irgendwie vielleicht
was ist, wo die Leute sagen so, wir dürfen die Daten nicht speichern,
das ist alles anonym, wir kriegen auch nicht deinen Namen, deswegen brauchen
wir jetzt mal deinen Personalausweis.
Kann ich mir vorstellen.
Aber das sehen die Leute nicht so.
Das sehen die nicht so?
Ne die sehen das nicht, dass das ein anonymer Vorgang ist, wenn du da deinen Schmerz dran hältst.
Ja genau, könnte sein, dass die UX jetzt nicht nahelegt, dass das gerade ein anonymer Vorgang ist.
Zumal der ja noch mit Strahlen stattfindet, mit Funk.
Dann kriegst du irgendwie Hodenkrebs.
Also das kann ich mir vorstellen, dass das nochmal schwierig zu vermitteln wird.
Aber ok, Alterskontrolle ist ja für uns beide eh kein Problem.
Du findest uns das egal.
Nach unten oder nach oben?
Nach oben gibt es da bisher noch keine Beschränkungen, Tim, keine Sorge.
Nein, nach oben gibt es da keine Beschränkungen, Tim, keine Sorge. Noch nicht.
Aber das Problem mit der Alterskontrolle ist ja,
dass das in eine Richtung führt,
die eben durch, weil es eben sehr schwierig ist,
eine Alterskontrolle durchzuführen, die korrekt ist und nicht mit einer Identitätskontrolle
verbunden ist, wird dieses Thema ja so heiß diskutiert.
Und da jetzt die EU sich ja eigentlich selten Sorgen darüber macht,
auch etwas zu fordern, was technisch aktuell nicht möglich ist,
zum Beispiel eine KI, die Kindesmissbrauchsdarstellungen erkennt,
können sie ja genauso fordern, du darfst die Sachen nicht speichern,
du darfst keine biometrischen Daten erheben und du musst das machen.
Also ist ja völlig in Ordnung, können ja machen, bleibt ihnen ja unbenommen.
Außerdem Netzsperren, die dürfen jetzt nur noch angeordnet werden,
wenn dadurch keine sonstigen legalen Inhalte blockiert werden.
Und die sollen erst dann in Frage kommen, wenn die Inhalte nicht gelöscht werden konnten.
Also die alte Forderung, löschen statt sperren.
Die steckt da drin. Also, man könnte...
Sich vorstellen, dass jetzt irgendwie ein entsprechendes Material auf einer
auf einer Domain gehostet wird, wo auch andere Sachen gehostet werden.
Und dann muss also jetzt beispielsweise, es gibt ja tatsächlich Pornoseiten,
die auch in der Vergangenheit sehr oft dadurch aufgefallen sind,
nicht rechtmäßige Inhalte zu hosten.
Insbesondere erinnern wir uns an X-Hamster. Einige erinnern sich wahrscheinlich
an den Fall bei verschiedenen Musik-Festivals in Deutschland,
wo Filme angefertigt wurden, teilweise von Duschsituationen,
teilweise von Toilettensituationen, die dann auf XHamster bereitgestellt wurden,
in der Kategorie Voyeur, wo wahrscheinlich eine ganze Menge gestellte voyeuristische
Videos sind und einige wenige, wo Menschen gegen ihren Willen gefilmt wurden,
so die Darstellung von XHamster.
Jetzt könnte es ja sein, dass ich unter diesen in vielen Videos,
die es auf dieser Webseite gibt, Material befindet, was illegal ist,
da müsste zunächst die Anstrengung unternommen werden, dass es gelöscht wird,
also beispielsweise Betreiber angeschrieben oder oder oder.
Und wenn sich dann herausstellt, dass das eben nicht passiert,
dann kann man also hier eine Netzsperre anordnen.
Das dürfte aber auch Das würde bedeuten, dass das relativ selten vorkommt und
die Behörden müssen das auch nicht anordnen. Es bleibt ihnen freigestellt.
Das ist, glaube ich, ganz gut, das heißt für alles, was halbwegs legal ist und
sich im normalen Einzugsbereich bezieht,
ist das eine Keule, mit der sie drohen können und für alles,
was notorisch ist und außerhalb des Einzugsbereichs der Behörden kann man dann
diese Netzsperren machen.
Klingt jetzt erstmal nach einer ausgewogenen Idee.
Ich bin kein Freund von Netzsperren. Es ist auch größtenteils unsinnig,
das zu machen, weil solange etwas irgendwo im Internet erreichbar ist,
wird es auch weiterhin über VPN oder Tor oder andere DNS-Server immer weiter erreichbar bleiben.
Das ist eine unsinnige Maßnahme, aber sie in einen Kontext zu setzen,
wo eine ganze Menge Bedingungen vorher erfüllt werden müssen,
bevor das jemand anordnen kann, und dann bleibt sie immer noch umgehbar, scheint mir.
Nicht meine größte Sorge zu sein. Außerdem wollen die Liebeberichterstatter
auch das Scannen nach Grooming rausnehmen.
Grooming wäre also, dass die Textinhalte untersucht werden darauf,
ob hier potenziell eine erwachsene Person mit einem Kind versucht,
eine Anbahnung vorzunehmen.
Das steht aber, glaube ich, eher so unter ferner liefen.
Und jetzt ist dieser Kompromiss halt vorgestellt worden, der ist aber noch nicht
wirklich so verabschiedet worden.
Das sieht aber ganz gut danach aus. Und dann gab es jetzt natürlich auch schon
relativ frohlockende Berichterstattung.
Zum Beispiel hat Patrick Breyer, der war ja bei uns auch schon in der Sendung
zu dem Thema, der hat das Thema vor zwei Jahren, bevor es wirklich auf der Agenda
war, schon immer behandelt, ist da als Europaabgeordneter unermüdlich dran.
Der hat das jetzt schon, hat da so ein Briefing zugemacht und hat jetzt,
also natürlich sind jetzt alle erstmal positiver gestimmt,
weil es sich hier um einen Kompromisstext handeln könnte, der,
wenn er denn so beschlossen wird, tatsächlich kann man davon sagen,
dass dann viele Giftzähne der Chat-Kontrolle-Verordnung gezogen wurden.
Aber, wenn der Rat das jetzt beschließt, dann findet ja immer noch der Trilog
statt, in dem dann Ministerrat, Parlament und Kommission sich einigen müssen.
Du meinst, wenn das Parlament das beschließt?
Was habe ich gesagt?
Der Rat. Der Rat geht in den Trilog rein, aber das ist ja jetzt von dem Lieberausschuss,
das ist sozusagen der Kompromiss des Parlaments.
Und das geht dann in den Trilog, wo der Rat mit der Kommission und dem Parlament
und dann eben mit diesem Kompromiss sozusagen kommt das Parlament an und sagt, so hätten wir es gern.
Okay, also du hast korrekt.
Das ist jetzt ein Kompromiss aus dem Lieberausschuss. Richtig. Alles richtig.
Und der ist im Parlament angesiedelt. Ich weiß das ist alles super verwirrend,
aber das kann man an der Stelle schon mal klar machen.
Das ist aber auch heilig, weil wir das jedes Mal sagen. Jedes Mal wenn wir eine U-Gesetz geben.
Ist ja auch egal. Also der Lieberausschuss, der hat sozusagen jetzt im Parlament
versucht Kompromiss zu machen, mit dem man in diesen Trilog reingeht.
Und ich frage mich halt, wie kommt das dann an?
Ich habe den Eindruck gewonnen,
dass im Rat relativ viel Widerstand ist von einzelnen Ländern gegenüber den
ursprünglichen Plänen,
sodass da nicht so eine Front ist mit jetzt hauen wir da aber voll drauf,
sondern die sehnen sich in gewisser Hinsicht nach einem Kompromiss und dann
könnte das dem schon ziemlich nahe kommen.
Genau, dann ist aber natürlich noch die Kommission und das Problem,
also der Trilog ist immer so, das ist eigentlich das Gefährlichste, weil dann haben die,
wenn da jetzt ein Kompromiss vom Parlament kommt und dann gehen die in den Trilog
und dann setzt sich aus irgendwelchen Gründen die Kommission doch nochmal mit
irgendeinem Unsinn durch, dann ist das eben so.
Ja, das heißt, also dieser Prozess
ist ja wirklich auch erschwerend und wahrscheinlich wird man irgendwann,
wird die KI darüber lachen, was sie hier für einen Quatsch gemacht haben,
aber es ist halt zu früh,
sich jetzt zu freuen, es geht in eine positive Richtung,
aber dieser Trilog ist halt eine relativ gefährliche Angelegenheit und alle,
die das jetzt gesehen haben und diesen Prozess längere Zeit beobachten,
sagen halt, es ist nicht der Moment,
um jetzt in Freudentänze auszubrechen, aber es ist natürlich schon der Moment,
um anzuerkennen, dass es hier einen sinnvollen Vorschlag gibt,
der nun bitte auch verfolgt werden muss.
Aber wenn jetzt quasi die Aufmerksamkeit und der Protest aufhören,
weil man denkt, ah ja, okay, gibt jetzt einen Kompromiss, das ist natürlich
die Gefahr, dann kann man sich überlegen, oder kann man befürchten,
dass es nochmal irgendwo umgekippt wird und dann keiner mehr hinguckt.
Insofern sind alle Verhalten positiv gestimmt, aber...
Man würde sich eigentlich wünschen, dass der Kompromiss im Liebeausschuss noch
etwas radikaler diese ursprünglichen Vorschläge ablehnen würde,
damit man sagen kann, wir können uns nur in der Mitte treffen, der ungefähr so ist.
Weil wenn das jetzt sozusagen deine Verhandlungsbasis ist, kann es noch ein
bisschen schlimmer werden.
Aber ich glaube auch, dass die Einheit im Rat nicht so groß ist und inwiefern die Kommission...
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ehrlich gesagt, da müsste man mal Gelegenheit vielleicht
mal mit irgendeinem der Europapolitiker nochmal drüber sprechen.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, welchen Einfluss die Kommission wirklich im Trilog hat.
Also klar, es sind schon drei Parteien, die dort beteiligt sind,
aber ich habe schon immer so den Eindruck gewonnen in den letzten Jahren,
dass das so primär ein Battle zwischen Parlament und Rat ist oder kurz gesagt
Parlament und die europäischen Regierungen.
Das ist das, was der Rat ist. Das ist sozusagen die Regierung,
die immer sagen, ja in Europa geht ja nichts voran und die beschließen ganz furchtbare Sachen,
aber es sind halt die Regierungen selbst, die direkt sozusagen mit ihrer Vertretung
im Europarat am Ende in diesen Trilogen durchsetzen, was gemacht werden soll.
Und ja, keine Ahnung.
Frau Johansson hat sich ja jetzt auch nicht sonderlich mit Ruhm bekleckert in
dieser ganzen Geschichte. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das sozusagen die
Position der Kommission und in dem Fall ist es ja sie vor allem, geschwächt ist.
Also wir haben ja jetzt hier schon behandelt, was sie an welchen Vorwürfen sie
sich aussetzen musste. Ich finde das auch immer lustig, dass das dann bei Politikern...
Also ich habe so ein bisschen das Eindruck, die Leute sind immer so ein bisschen
vorsichtig mit einfach mal einem Politiker Korruption vorzuwerfen.
Amthor mit seinem, mit diesem, wie hieß der nochmal, Augustus-Intelligence-Scam.
Ja, das Ding ist ja jetzt auch inzwischen geplatzt. Dann gab es Lobbying-Vorwürfe gegen den Politiker.
Oder hier, Eva Johansson hat irgendwie Lobbyisten bei sich, an dem Ding selber
arbeiten. Ja, die sind in den Organisationen, die davon profitieren und dafür
kämpfen. Und dann gibt es einen Lobbying-Skandal.
Das ist ein Korruptionsskandal in meinen Augen. Aber okay, was dann noch aufgekommen
ist, das hat man, glaube ich, gar nicht behandelt.
Oder ist seit der letzten Sendung
noch dazugekommen. Also über die Verstrickungen haben wir gesprochen,
dass sie ihre Mitarbeiter in den Lobbyorganisationen sind für dieses Thema,
dass diese Lobbyorganisationen wiederum wirtschaftliche Arme haben,
in denen sie die Technologie bauen und nach außen sich aber darstellen,
als wären sie irgendwelche Kinderschutzorganisationen. Alles bekannt.
Außerdem hat die Johansson auch noch eine Microtargeting-Kampagne gemacht,
um für dieses Proposal zu stimmen.
Und Microtargeting ist das, dass man sehr detaillierte Zielgruppen auswählt
in sozialen Netzwerken, wie zum Beispiel Twitter oder Facebook.
Und das ist im Prinzip das, was unter dem Cambridge Analytica Skandal bekannt
wurde, der oder die Öffentlichkeit sich endlich mal damit auseinandergesetzt hat, ja.
Und der Digital Service Act will eigentlich sowas auch einschränken und verhindern.
Das heißt, der EU ist bekannt, dass Microtargeting ein Problem ist,
das sie potenziell regulieren, verbieten, einschränken muss.
Und die Johansson denkt so, oh ja, Microtarget, das klingt eigentlich genau
nach dem, was ich jetzt brauche, um mit meinen Lobbyisten hier zusammen dieses
Proposal durchzubringen.
Das ist ein Fass ohne Boden, diese ganze Chat-Kontrollenummer.
Ich find's wirklich irre.
Also nicht nur, dass die EU das beschlossen hat, ja, dass Micro-Targeting ein
Problem ist, sondern das fällt in ihr Ressort.
Ja gut, dass du das nochmal sagst. Deswegen kennt die sich auch damit aus.
Ach was ist das denn hier, das ist ja interessant, das können wir mal ausprobieren.
Und da kann ich jetzt hier jet-controlle.
Also das ist wirklich ein Skandal. Es ist ein Skandal. Also okay,
ein Kompromiss liegt da.
Es wäre vor allem, also was natürlich jetzt auch eine Rolle spielt an diesem
Kompromiss, oder was für mich eine Frage ist an diesem Kompromiss.
Ich hab mir schon vor Längerem gedacht, also die Ilva Johansson hat sich natürlich
echt weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt. Richtig weit.
Und sie musste sich jetzt zu diesen Korruptions- und Lobby-Vorwürfen äußern
und sie hat sich da nicht zufriedenstellend geäußert.
Sie hat, das ist ihr Stück, ihr Meisterinnenstück, mit dem sie auch aus dieser
Legislaturperiode raus will und so, die hat alles auf diese Karte gesetzt.
Und ich hatte ja vor allem die große Sorge, dass man die nicht loswerden wird,
weil sie alles auf diese Karte gesetzt hat und weil sie da natürlich jetzt auch
einen Sieg braucht, wenn sie das nicht hat. Ihr Name ist so gut damit verbunden.
Und natürlich auch der Name vieler anderer, dass sie da jetzt auch irgendwie
was braucht zum Zeigen, sonst hat sie nämlich gar nix zu zeigen.
Und dieser Kompromissvorschlag, der da jetzt irgendwie rumgeistert,
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, ist besser als alles, was ich noch an Optionen
überhaupt realistisch gesehen habe.
Weil mir eigentlich klar war, irgendetwas werden die am Ende beschließen müssen,
weil das die nichts beschlossen haben.
Die will ja nicht dastehen wie der Thierry Breton, der irgendwie ein paar Jahre
da redet von seiner Datenmaut für
den Google und jetzt wurde das Ding eingesackt und jetzt hat er gar nix.
Jetzt muss er zurück zu seinen ehemaligen Arbeitgebern in der Telco-Branche
gehen und sagen, ja scheiße Jungs, habt ihr mich hier installiert,
habt ihr gedacht, ich hole euch die große Kohle, hab ich nicht geschafft.
Das ist peinlich, das ist peinlich für den jetzt.
Und das möchte die Eva Johansson ja nicht.
Wenn dieser Kompromiss sich durchsetzt, würde ich sagen,
dann sind halt wirklich eine ganze Reihe Giftzähne gezogen worden und das wäre gemessen an dem,
was da ursprünglich mal angerollt kam, ein sehr glimpflicher Ausgang mit potenziell
sehr geringen Problemen.
Aber es gibt halt noch genug Möglichkeiten, da Probleme wieder reinzumogeln.
Ja, guck mal, also ich teile deine Einschätzung, dass das irgendwie besser klingt,
als man es hätte jetzt erwarten können und das zeugt natürlich davon,
dass hier die europäischen Netzpolitikerinnen gute Arbeit geleistet haben,
so habe ich so den Eindruck, auf allen Ebenen,
sowohl was den Druck in den eigenen Ländern betrifft, das haben wir in Deutschland
gesehen, vielleicht jetzt nicht ganz so viel Erfolg, aber ich glaube so Länder
wie Finnland und so weiter sind glaube ich immer noch sehr dagegen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal. Ciao.
Ich weiß aber jetzt nicht mehr genau welche das waren, das mag auch so eine
Tagesform sein, aber dann eben in dem Moment, wo es dann auch in dem Liebeausschuss
stattfindet, dann ist es ja sozusagen auch im Parlament angekommen.
Und das ist ein gutes Zeichen. Siehste, die goldenen Zwanziger,
man sieht sie, wenn man den Vorhang ein bisschen mal aufmacht.
Ja, genau.
Dann kommen schon erste Lichtstrahlen durch. Was ich… Wahlen in Polen,
ich sag dir, also, okay, Wahlen in Slowenien, in Slowakei war wiederum ein Totalausfall,
aber zumindest das Polenproblem sind wir jetzt erstmal los für eine Weile.
Aber du hast recht, es sieht gerade nach einem glimpflichen Ausgang aus und
wir bleiben verhalten positiv,
aber gerade so eine Debatte,
die kann halt auch sehr schnell sehr gerne schief gehen und potenziell können wir,
wenn das jetzt wirklich am Ende nicht schief geht, Können wir uns dann vielleicht
rühmen hier einen demokratischen Prozess gesehen zu haben,
der am Ende noch der Ratio und der Vernunft zum Tragen verholfen hat.
Das haben nicht mehr, das gelingt gerade einigen Demokratien nicht in dem Ausmaß,
wie das hier sich potenziell abzeichnen könnte.
Tja, Demokratie kann doch ein bisschen was.
Naja, so weit würde ich nicht gehen.
Dann haben wir ein Thema.
Ein Jubiläum.
Jubiläum?
Ach nee, Entschuldigung. Ich bin in der...
Können wir auch erst noch machen. Da fällt mir übrigens ein Kommentar ein,
den wir auch hatten, aber ich glaube, irgendwo anders her, deswegen haben wir
nicht kommentiert, nicht in der Sendung gegangen. Wir haben uns über gewundert
über Xita als Bezeichnung für Twitter.
Erinnerst du dich? Ja. Und das wurde mir, ich glaube auf Mastodon,
dass das Xita, das spricht man gar nicht so aus, sondern das kennst du den Präsidenten von China.
Ja, Xi.
Und wie spricht man den Namen aus?
Xi, da schreibt man X, I, aber ehrlich gesagt, die Assoziation habe ich jetzt nicht bekommen.
Und Xita, ja, das wäre auch jetzt schwer, das zu behaupten, weil wir haben ja
sehr lange darüber gesprochen und das ist für alle Hörerinnen nachvollziehbar,
dass wir diese Assoziation nicht hatten.
Deswegen wurden wir auf Mastodon korrigiert, es heißt Chitta,
aber man schreibt es mit X.
Überzeugt mich nicht so richtig. Dann soll man lieber Chitta mit SH schreiben,
dann ist zumindest klar was gemeint ist.
Ich bleib bei Twix.
Humorkritik. Nee, ich weiß nicht, wenn wir was falsch aussprechen,
fragst du Chetchipiti, was lustiger ist?
Man kann da schon, naja, müssen wir jetzt nicht vertiefen, man kann sich da
schon interessante Vorschläge machen lassen, was sowas betrifft.
Aber es ist jetzt ein Jahr her, ne?
Genau, das ist ein Jahr her, dass Elon Musk Twitter übernommen hat.
Also ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was jetzt das Datum... 28.10.
Hat er irgendwie getwittert, der Vogel ist frei oder sowas. Das ist noch zwei Tage dann.
Wo er dann mit seiner Kloschüssel da irgendwie schon ins Haus reingerannt ist?
War in den Waschbecken. Waschbecken. Sink.
Kloschüssel war das wahrscheinlich. Nee, in den Sink. Der Typ der pinkelt auch ins Waschbecken.
Er hat ja in unser Waschbecken gepinkelt.
Und ja, es ist scheiße gelaufen, kann man mal echt sagen.
Und ich muss auch zugeben, dass ich da am Anfang noch nicht das richtige Maß
an Pessimismus am Start hatte.
Also es ist deutlich schlimmer geworden als ich dachte und ich hab mich auch
ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen gewundert,
dass er so durchdreht, also dass er auch so eine latente Arschlochnummer,
okay gut so, das kennt man ja bei vielen, aber mittlerweile ist er ja zum fullblown
Nazi und Putin Versteher geworden, da ist ja überhaupt nichts mehr zu retten bei dem Kerl.
Also da könnt ihr mal sehen leute geld macht nicht nur nicht glücklich macht doch doof.
Deswegen wird er jetzt auch richtig viel davon los also der twitter wert den
hat er ja offenbar ganz gut dezimiert die 40 milliarden die er dafür mal hinlegen musste.
Die wird er jetzt so so nicht unbedingt wieder bekommen also wenn er jetzt eine
anschlussfinanzierung sucht oder so.
Ich hab ja, also das ist ja, ich hab ja relativ lange den Typen auch noch mindestens
für so rational gehalten, dass er nicht so blöd sein wird, diese Plattform zu kaufen, ne.
Und, also da, da, da, da, da muss ich ja auch dann leider sagen,
dass ich ihn überschätzt habe, um nicht zu sagen, dass ich mich einfach,
dass ich einfach falsch lag.
Aber man steht daneben und staunt, was er macht.
Und ich bin auch ganz ehrlich, dass ich das nach wie vor schade finde.
Das Ganze jetzt bin ich aber hier auf Blue Sky glücklich oder so,
oder auf Mastodon ist viel cooler.
Immer noch, das Twitter. Also in der Qualität, in der, es gibt's halt jetzt nicht mehr, ne?
In der, und die Auswahl an Timeline und so, die ich da hatte,
das habe ich mir einfach über viele Jahre zusammengestellt und über viele Jahre
weiterentwickelt, mit mir selber vielleicht auch weiterentwickelt.
Und das stelle ich fest, dass das, egal wo mich jetzt Leute hinlocken,
nicht so einfach gelingt, das sofort wieder aufzubauen. Es gibt natürlich Möglichkeiten, ja.
Und bei Blue Sky, wie du ja auch letztes Mal sagtest, da tummeln sich dann jetzt
schon relativ viele Twitteraner oder viele Leute, die ich von Twitter kenne.
Aber und das ist, das macht man erst einen guten Eindruck vielleicht.
Aber das ist jetzt auch weit davon entfernt, mir den Kick wieder zu den fix
wieder zu geben von twitter ich habe mein also das positive ist mein social
media konsum ist halt absolut im keller.
Das kann auch was gutes sein.
Ist positiv.
Ja also ich habe mittlerweile meine meine quellen weitgehend weggezogen von
von twitter also das was was ich zuletzt auf twitter noch genossen habe kriege
ich jetzt tatsächlich über telegram.
Naja, weil da die Quellen sind, für die Twitter bisher eigentlich immer nur
ihre Zweitverwertung war, ne?
Achso, jaja, okay, bei dir geht's jetzt spezifisch um deine Ukraine.
Konfliktbeobachter generell sind einfach sehr aktiv gewesen.
Jaja, okay, da bist du da natürlich sehr gut.
Und da hat sich aber Telegram mittlerweile als die viel bessere Plattform herausgestellt,
weil das einfach nochmal viel besser funktioniert tatsächlich.
Also ich bin auch immer wieder erstaunt darüber, wie gut Telegram ist.
Ich würde jetzt sogar mal ausrufen, das erfolgreichste Kommunikationsmodell,
was das Internet bisher hervorgebracht hat und das jetzt schon seit 30 Jahren, heißt Chat.
Chat rules everything.
Instant Messenger, Slack und Consorten, diese ganzen Sachen früher schon,
IRC und auch in den aller aller aller ersten dunklen Multi-User-Unix-Zeiten
gab's schon irgendwie einfache Chat-Systeme,
die ersten Computer-Mailboxen, da war Chat war immer die Killer-App, immer.
Und jetzt sehen wir irgendwie Chat, wir haben schon drüber gesprochen,
belebt die KI, es wird zum User Interface, es wird zum News Verteiler,
es ist tausend mal besser als so viele andere Sachen, ist wirklich erstaunlich.
Aber was ist mit Sprana Tim? Ich weiß nicht was das sein soll.
Sprachnachrichten. Ja ne, also man kann auch eine Sprachnachricht in Chat werfen,
aber sie ist dann immer noch im Chat.
Also die Chat als strukturierendes Element.
Ja, Gruppen, persönliche Nachrichten, Timeline, alles steckt da drin in Chat und Chat nimmt es auf.
Und Twitter war jetzt schön, wird aber so glaube ich nie wieder kommen,
es wird nur in Teilen nachgebildet werden von den anderen Systemen,
es wird seine Bedeutung noch haben, es wird da sein, aber in gewisser Hinsicht
war ja auch Twitter, also das war meine ursprüngliche Voraussage,
als ich das erste Mal The Power of Twitter gespürt habe, war,
das wird der globale Chat.
Und ich glaube mit der Einschätzung lag ich jetzt so falsch,
nicht unbedingt. Und der globale Chat ist uns jetzt durch Elon Musk genommen worden, so.
Also es gibt noch einen globalen Chat aber da unterhalten sich halt jetzt einfach
nur noch die Nazis und ob andere Plattformen noch genauso global werden können wie Twitter,
weil es sozusagen das einzige System dieser Art war, was nennenswerten Reach hatte, muss ich zeigen.
Und es ist ja nicht nur Mastodon und Blue Sky die jetzt hier konkurrieren,
es ist vor allem, lungert im Hintergrund ja dieses Threads von Facebook,
von Meta, von Zuckerberg.
Was ich nicht benutze, was ja offiziell auch in Europa eigentlich nicht in Betrieb
ist, aber vielleicht dann doch irgendwann nochmal kommen wird.
Auch irgendwie so ähnlich funktioniert, aber halt diese übliche Schnaßes mit
irgendwie ja, dein Instagram Account und dann kannst du das alles wieder nicht
löschen und ist alles ganz furchtbar.
Ich hab auch ehrlich gesagt keinen Bock auf Meta, da lieber Meta-Ebene als Meta.
Also Twitter ist durch. Das kann man nicht mehr benutzen. Die Software ist scheiße.
Jetzt haben sie irgendwie, ich meine es ist schon so lustig,
jetzt haben sie ein Video und Audio Chat Feature vorgestellt.
Erster Artikel, den ich dazu entdeckt habe ist, X is now rolling out audio and
video calls. And here is how to turn them off.
Das ist wie früher im Netz, die mussten auch jedes mal zu jedem neuen Facebook
Feature irgendwie sagen, wo man das wieder
abschalten kann und wie man die Datenschutzeinstellung und so. Genau.
Fand ich schon ganz interessant, weil die Leute einfach einen schnauzevoll haben,
von nein packt nicht doch irgendwas rein, das ist doch einfach was,
das ist wahr, war doch super, war doch super, man.
Elon Musk träumt halt davon aus Twitter so ein, wie heißt das nochmal in China?
The Everything App, WeChat.
WeChat zu sein, womit man bezahlt und so weiter.
Dieses ganze damit bezahlen Ding, das steckt bei denen so dermaßen im Kopf,
weil ich meine, wenn du mal guckst, was für Leuten der sich umgibt,
das sind ja auch alles so Krypto-Bros.
Auch der Vogel der Twitter gestaltet hat, die hängen alle da noch in diesem
Bitcoin Nirvana fest gedanklich und wollen das auch nicht hergeben. Hauptsache Geld.
Ich glaube nicht, dass der da mit Crypto Coins am Ende bezahlen will,
sondern dass der wahrscheinlich irgendwie einfach Gebühren nehmen möchte,
das ist ein Geschäftsmodell, was ich äußerst einleuchtend finde.
Also wenn du dir anschaust, diejenigen die es geschafft haben,
Die haben damit ja einfach eine Gelddruckmaschine und die, die es nicht geschafft
haben, versuchen das natürlich trotzdem.
Ich meine, gewissermaßen, da hat dann selbst die Luca App gleiche Anspruch wie
Elon Musk, da streben sie alle nach.
Luca App will ja auch irgendwie so ein Payment Ding werden.
Deutsches Schild da, ja. Wir,
nehmen irgendwas, wo viele User drauf sind und versuchen da irgendwie eine Bezahl-App
draus zu machen. Geile Idee, super.
Mit russischer Kohle.
Mein Gott, baut doch einfach mal was, was Leuten gefällt.
Genau, also erstaunlich. Also erstaunlich, was er da macht. Und es ist ja nicht,
also es ist entweder durch einen wirklich übelnden,
politisch motivierten Move zu erklären,
aber ich habe wirklich den Eindruck, also es mag ja sein, was er machen wird,
ist, er verliert halt, das Ding verliert die Relevanz, ne?
Und dann ist auch völlig egal, was da für Nazis, was für eine Scheiße reden.
Das ist dann egal in dem Moment, weil der wirkliche Wert von Twitter war,
dass da eben die Medien lauern auf Neuigkeiten.
Und wenn da niemand mehr ist, bei dem die Medien darauf lauern,
dass er Neuigkeiten bringt, außer irgendwie Donald Trump oder so,
dann ist das Ding halt durch.
Und da sieht's gerade ganz gut nach aus. Und das scheint mir dann für das Geld,
was Elon Musk sich da geliehen hat, echt scheiße auszusehen.
Das ist aber jetzt woanders. Das ist bei denen, und eigentlich auch lustig,
das ganze Geld ist jetzt bei denen, die damals in Twitter, was keine aussichtsreiche
Online-Plattform war, Potenzial gesehen haben und die Aktien besessen haben.
So bei denen ist das geld jetzt und die
haben doch die haben ja an was ordentliches geglaubt die haben ja ein also fair
Kapitalismus fair das geld ist jetzt bei denen
die an twitter geglaubt haben und die haben die kohle eingestrichen und der
jetzt ist es halt im arsch also die müssen sich da auch irgendwie freuen Einfach
weg ja die wird back to the shareholder ist das haben sie gemacht Ja,
das ist doch mal eine kapitalistische Erfolgsgeschichte.
Absolut. Eigentlich ist es schon Dumpster-Feier und dann bekaufst du es an einen,
der sagt, der löscht es und dann springt der halt rein in den Dumpster,
rührt um und gießt ein bisschen Öl nach und du sagst, super,
Hammer, schweingehaft, dass die Scheiße noch losgeworden sind.
Ja, nur wir, die wir noch an den Wert geglaubt haben, wir stehen da im Regen.
Capitalism cares for you.
Das hat der Markt geregelt. Twitter hat der Markt geregelt.
Er hat überlegt, ob wir noch ein bisschen über KI reden wollen oder ob wir das
mal in die nächste Sendung.
Ach nee, jetzt haben wir schon so viel über KI geredet, jetzt bin ich in dem
Mut. Lass uns doch da gleich reinrutschen.
Ja dann will ich, also ich habe in diesem Jahr mehrere Vorträge zu dem Thema gehalten,
mehrere Workshops besucht, teilweise mehrtägige, mit vielen Leuten darüber geredet
und natürlich auch so mit vielen Menschen, denen das Thema jetzt so gar nichts sagt.
Mit vielen Menschen, die sich von beruflicher Seite, sagen wir vielleicht irgendwie,
als Unternehmerinnen oder Führungskräfte damit auseinandersetzen müssen, gesprochen.
Und das ist jetzt auch so ungefähr ein Jahr, dass das so alles abgeht.
Und was ich da sehr, sehr unterhaltsam daran finde, was mir so auffällt,
ist, diese Technologie wird massiv unterschätzt und massiv überschätzt.
Und ich glaube, das liegt daran, dass sie KI genannt wird, obwohl sie eigentlich
Machine Learning oder Deep Learning heißen sollte, weil das der richtige Begriff ist.
Und was mich gerade sehr fasziniert, sind ja eigentlich immer so die Glitches
darin. Wir haben es hier vor Jahren, als das ganze Thema aufkam,
habe ich ja schon auch so die Vorträge von Joscha Bach empfohlen.
Und ich mag halt diese Halluzinationen, Glitches,
Fehldinge, die falsche Dinge, die das Ding sagt, weil sie so aufschlussreich
darüber sind, weil sie so viel Aufschluss darüber geben, wie das tatsächlich
funktioniert und wie die lernen.
Und wir haben, ich weiß nicht, ob ich das hier erwähnt hatte,
ich hatte mit meinem Kollegen Jannis einen Vortrag gehalten über im Prinzip
Artificial Intelligence oder Deep Learning, Machine Learning bei der Heise Security Show.
Heise Security Tour heißt das, glaube ich.
Also es gab in unterschiedlichen Städten so Live-Events und Online-Events und
so, wo die halt von Heise veranstaltet werden, vom Heise Verlag.
Und der Janis hat Machine Learning
quasi studiert und dann in dem Bereich proboviert als Mathematiker.
Und ich bin ja von der Ausbildung her eigentlich Psychologe.
Ich habe nur bis auf ein paar Unis jetzt nie als Psychologe gearbeitet,
erst recht nicht als Therapeut.
Immer in der IT-Sicherheit, so wie der Janis auch. Und da haben wir quasi einen
Vortrag darüber gestaltet. Und ich glaube, das war ganz interessant,
weil wir einerseits ich als Psychologen wahrscheinlich relativ gutes Verständnis
davon habe, was Intelligenz ist.
Und Janis als jemand, der mit diesen Modellen arbeitet, ein relativ gutes Verständnis
davon hat, was die können und wo die Herausforderungen sind.
Und wir, uns fällt so ein bisschen auf, dass, Also weil es spricht, kann es jetzt alles.
Im Prinzip hat man mit Deep Learning jetzt zwei Dinge geschafft.
Einmal diese ganzen Large Language Models, das Reden, und dann das Bildermalen.
Und vielleicht noch ein bisschen Musik machen oder so, was aber verhältnismäßig
trivial ist im Vergleich zu den anderen beiden Dingen.
Ja doch, von den Daten ist es sehr viel einfacher, Musik einem solchen Modell
beizubringen, als das Malen von Bildern.
Der Raum, den irgendwie Töne ausmachen, der ist relativ simpel.
Also Noten sind relativ simpel. Und das ist massenhaft vorhanden,
das Futter, das Lernfutter für so eine KI.
Das ist also verhältnismäßig triviale Aufgabe im Vergleich zu diesen Bildern,
die wir jetzt hier als Episoden-Images machen.
Und was, glaube ich, vielen Leuten so ein bisschen fehlt, ist ein Verständnis
dafür, was diese Dinger lernen können und was nicht.
Oder was die Voraussetzungen sind dafür, dass sie etwas lernen.
Ich stelle mir das immer so ein bisschen vor, oder ich visualisiere das eigentlich
so ein bisschen wie so ein Bernoulli-Brett. Kennst du ein Bernoulli-Brett?
Bernoulli-Brett? Also es gibt eine Bernoulli-Gleichung?
Ja, genau. Stell dir das vor wie
einfach ein Brett, auf dem in gleichen Abständen ganz viele Nägel sind.
Und jetzt wirfst du oben eine Kugel rein, ne?
Und dann kann die Kugel an jedem Nagel, wird dir entweder nach rechts oder links fallen.
Und wenn du das jetzt einmal machst, kannst du nicht sagen,
wo die Kugel landen wird, weil die könnte halt immer wieder nach links fallen,
ab und zu fällt sie mal nach rechts, die kann in der Mitte ankommen und wenn
du das jetzt oft genug machst,
dann verteilen sich die Kugeln im Prinzip in so einer Bernoulli-Verteilung da
unten, weil es eben sehr unwahrscheinlich wird, dass sie ganz nach rechts kommt,
sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass sie ganz nach links kommt, relativ wahrscheinlich
ist, dass sie in der Mitte landet, aber nicht alle Kugeln dann in der Mitte.
Das heißt, die fällt da so durch. Aber sie fällt nicht deterministisch da durch.
Aber du kannst in der großen Zahl am Ende schon sehen, was die Eigenschaften
dieses Bernoulli-Bretts sind.
Und so ungefähr muss man sich ja eine...
Vorstellen, nur dass es halt viele viele tausend Verbindungen gibt und die gehen
auch nicht alle in eine Richtung,
sondern wie Neuronen in unserem Hirn gehen die in alle Richtungen und alle viele
Neurone sind über viele Aktionen verbunden in einer nicht notwendigerweise und
insbesondere nicht unbedingt linearen Verbindung.
Darf ich dich kurz korrigieren? Es ist das Galton-Brett, nicht das Benuit-Brett,
was du das galtonische Nagelbrett oder Zufallsbrett.
Okay, dann ist es der Bernoulli-Versuch, der an diesem Brett durch vorgenommen wird.
Richtig, genau, da ist von Bernoulli die Rede, alles klar.
Ja, das ist der, jedes Aufprallen einer Kugel auf eines der Hindernisse ist
ein Bernoulli-Versuch.
Daraus resultiert die Bernoulli-Verteilung, genau.
Bernoulli-Verteilung, ja, okay, dann ist es das Galtonbrett,
an dem sich die Bernoulli-Verteilung abbilden lässt.
So ein wunderschöner Wikipedia-Artikel und also das ist aber jetzt,
die Kugel fällt ja nach unten.
Wenn du aber ein neuronales Netz hast, hast du Neurone feuern,
lösen auf, aus und regen weitere Neurone an und das als nicht mehr linearer
Prozess, Sondern als wenn man sich so Gehirne anschaut, die summen ja eigentlich.
Da findet kein linearer Prozess drin statt, sondern ein gleichzeitiger Prozess.
Das ist so ein bisschen so, was mich irgendwie völlig fertig gemacht hat,
als ich auf einmal hier so Hardware Design machen musste.
So mit Verilog und so.
Und da findet alles immer gleichzeitig statt. Du kannst,
wenn du Mikroprozessoren design machst oder mit FPGAs programmierst,
dann muss alles, was die machen, immer zu jedem Zeitpunkt passieren.
Das passiert alles immer gleichzeitig.
Wenn du jetzt irgendwie Software schreibst, dann schreibst du ja irgendwie,
okay beim ersten Mal passiert das, jetzt vergleichen wir mal das und wenn das
ist das und das ist das. Aber wenn du jetzt quasi Hardware-Logik machst, dann ist alles immer.
Genau, der Strom fließt überall, nicht nur an einer Stelle.
Genau, also das ist völliger Irrsinn, aber so funktioniert natürlich auch unser
Gehirn, das heißt es gibt darin keine linearen Prozesse, sondern alle Neuronen
machen in jedem theoretischen virtuellen Takt immer alles.
Lernen und so weiter. Das macht, das bildet sie nicht darin ab,
wie unsere Neuronen sind und auch nicht notwendigerweise, wie ihre Verbindungen
sind, sondern wie die Gewichtungen ihrer Verbindungen sind.
Also wie stark muss ein Neuron auslösen, damit es über die Verbindung das Nächste tatsächlich auslöst.
Und gleichzeitig ist das jetzt nicht von, kann ein Neuron,
Neuron kriegt quasi mehrere Eingänge und hat eine Schwelle,
also ich bin jetzt ein Neuron, bei mir gehen drei Verbindungen ein,
meine Schwelle ist eins und die eine Verbindung hat eine Stärke von 0,5,
die andere hat eine Stärke von 0,6 und die andere hat eine Stärke von 0,4.
Und wenn du jetzt die 6 und die 4 würden mich auslösen, die 0,5 und die 0,4
aber nicht, weil mein Schwellwert ist ja 1.
Und dann gleichzeitig integrieren die auch noch über die Zeit.
Also es ist halt, ah sorry, ich werd wahnsinnig gehirn… wahnsinnig.
Tim, es ist mein zweitliebstes Organ.
Wie Woody Allenheim als sagt.
Das war in unserem Lehrbuch über biologische Psychologie.
Auf dem Anfang war eine Walnuss abgebildet und da drunter stand,
the brain is my second favorite organ, Woody Allen. Und dann halt irgendwie
ein riesiges Buch über wie Gehirne funktionieren. Wunderschön.
Was ist dein Lieblingsorgan?
Ich weiß was mein Lieblingsorgan ist und verrätst du es uns?
Klar mein Herz, ja es liegt mir einiges dran, ja aber da sitzt spark joy.
Ich benutze es ja täglich, laufend eigentlich, öfter als mein Hirn.
Oh man, jetzt bin ich eben bei meiner Gehirnerklärung, neuronale Netzerklärung.
Macht ist, man postuliert eine Anzahl Neurone, man postuliert sie in Layern,
man postuliert auch Verbindungen und dann ballert man da Daten rein.
In dem klassischen Programmieren hast du Daten und wendest darauf Regeln an und machst ein Output.
Und beim Machine Learning hast du Daten und Output oder gewünschtes Output und
leitest daraus die Regeln ab.
Also du nimmst ganz viele Bilder und ihre Beschreibungen und trainierst das
Ding so lange, bis du eine Beschreibung gibst und der malt ein Bild.
Und diese Herangehensweise kannst du aber nur machen, wenn du relativ viele
Daten hast, also Unmengen an Daten, und diese Daten auch ordentlich gelabelt sind.
Also du kannst sagen, was richtig ist und was falsch oder was gewünschtes Output ist und was nicht.
Und die Aufgabe, die du lösen willst, ist nicht trivial.
Das sind die drei Voraussetzungen, vom Datensatz her, wo dir dieses Machine
Learning einen Vorteil gibt.
Oder wo du jetzt einen Durchbruch in der Informatik hast, weil man plötzlich
das schafft, diese Sache zu bändigen.
Und auch eher, weil jetzt mit den GPUs die Technik da ist, um das hinter sich
zu bringen, in dem Ausmaß an Neuronen und Verbindungen, die man jetzt braucht.
Und nicht, weil das jetzt wirklich, also auch Durchbrüche gab,
aber die grundsätzliche Herangehensweise war schon in den 60er Jahren klar.
Klar, es gab technische Weiterentwicklung und so weiter, haben wir ja auch schon
ein bisschen drüber gesprochen.
So, jetzt kannst du aber im Prinzip sagen, ich habe gesagt, viele Daten gut
gelabelt und ein nicht triviales Problem, weil viele Dinge, die Leute jetzt
postulieren, was KI jetzt machen wird.
Das heißt, dafür brauchst du gar kein Machine Learning, weil es zum Beispiel
eindeutige Lösungen gibt, weil der Lösungsraum begrenzt ist und sich in einer
einfachen linearen Gleichung abbilden lässt.
Was meinst du denn jetzt für ein Beispiel, was du jetzt damit meinst?
Also wo es jetzt schon eine andere Lösung gibt?
Preisgestaltung. Demnächst werden die Preise von einer KI bestimmt. So ein Quatsch.
Man weiß was ein Produkt kostet, man weiß ab wo das Verlust bringt und man weiß
es gibt eine eindimensionale Sache höher, teurer oder billiger da brauche ich
jetzt keine KI für, da guckst du einfach, also das ist eine, das ist eine, das ist.
Ich meine seh doch mal, wenn man jetzt die Preisgestaltung mit KI macht,
dann kann man endlich die fünf Blockchains abschalten, mit denen man sich zuletzt probiert hat.
Das ist natürlich gut. Leider sind die Blockchains wahrscheinlich das Lernmaterial
für die KI, weil man sonst keine strukturierten Daten hat.
Ich warte nur noch auf den Vortrag Künstliche Intelligenz auf der Blockchain.
Gibt es den noch nicht?
Bestimmt.
Das ist bestimmt schon eingereicht, ich sag dir Bescheid.
Ich lasse mir von Chachi richtig einschreiben.
Den reiche ich dann beim Kongress ein. Dann musst du den bewerten.
Aber schön geschrieben, so flüssig. Das wird euch jetzt auch so vorstehen.
Ich betone bitte warum dieser Vortrag wichtig ist.
Warum ihr gut zur Community passt.
So, jetzt haben wir also eine Menge Daten, gut gelabelt und ein nicht trivialer Lösungsraum.
Und wenn du dir das mal ansetzt als Maßstab,
dann leuchtet auch ein, warum mit dieser Technologie anfangs Schach und Go gespielt wurde,
weil du kriegst Unmengen an Spielen, ja,
diese ganzen Schach-Großmeister und so, das wird ja alles immer aufgezeichnet,
es ist auch super einfach aufzuzeichnen, weil am Ende bewegen sich nur ein paar
Figuren und der Lösungsraum ist aber halt endlos.
Also er ist unglaublich komplex.
Deswegen kannst du nicht mit einfacher Programmierung halt einen Schachgenie bauen.
Und was sie ja gemacht haben bei dem, ich glaube Deep Blue hieß dieser Schachcomputer
und AlphaGo, die haben den Dingern einfach nur Schachpartien oder Go-Partien
gefüttert, bis die irgendwann die Regeln konnten.
Was die den Dinger nie gesagt haben ist, wie die Regeln lauten.
Das Wissen darüber, wie die Regeln sind, was man darf und was nicht,
ist nirgendwo explizit in diesem neuronalen Modell hinterlegt.
Es ist implizit einfach nur in den vielen, vielen Verbindungen stärken,
dass egal welche Situation du oben, jetzt kommt wieder der Galton-Brett-Vergleich,
rein wirst, Unten fällt ein valider Zug raus und potenziell halt einer,
der dazu führt, dass du das Spiel in eine Richtung bewegst, wo du es irgendwann
nochmal gewinnen kannst, ne?
Und jetzt gehen die hin und haben gesagt, alles klar, wir haben jetzt eine KI,
die kann valide Züge generieren.
Und jetzt erklären wir, jetzt müssen wir nur noch sagen, wer wann gewonnen hat,
das versteht die auch noch.
Und dann haben wir einen Datenschatz, der unendlich ist.
Weil wer das Spiel gewonnen hat, das können wir ja relativ einfach erklären.
Was weiß ich, alle Figuren weg oder der König kann nicht mehr bewegt werden.
Oder bei Go weiß ich nicht, wann man da gewonnen hat. Das Spiel hab ich nie
verstanden oder nie gelernt.
Und jetzt sind die an dem Moment, wo sie in der Lage waren,
etwas zu bauen, was sich wie ein valider Spieler verhält oder eine valide Spielerin,
haben sie das einfach endlos gegeneinander spielen lassen und dann hat das Ding
sich einfach selber Go oder Schachball gebracht.
Und am Ende sind nur in den Verbindungen,
also nur implizit, war dann dieses Wissen drin oder der Erfahrungsschatz drin,
wie dieses Spiel zu spielen ist und wie man es gewinnt und auf eine Weise ist
das so ein relativ unfairer Vergleich, Weil wenn du dir anschaust,
wie alt die Leute waren gegen...
Hier die Blue gewonnen hat oder auch AlphaGo, die konnten in ihrem Leben ja
nur so und so viele Spiele von diesem Spiel spielen.
Und die wenigsten davon gegen Leute, die für sie noch eine Herausforderung dargestellt haben.
Und dann geht irgendwann halt dieses Ding hin, hat halt einfach mal wahrscheinlich
tausend oder millionenmal mehr dieses Spiel gespielt und gewinnt gegen die Menschen.
In einem, in diesem Fall dann eben nicht trivialen, Nicht triviale Herausforderung,
nämlich dieses ultra komplexe, nicht mathematisch erfassbare Spiel zu gewinnen,
auf Basis von Erfahrung.
Ich muss jetzt kurz eine Anmerkung machen, weil sonst steht das schon wieder
in den Kommentaren. Deep Blue war jetzt explizit kein KI System.
AlphaGo war das. AlphaGo ist sozusagen das erste, was jetzt wirklich mit diesen
Machine Learning Methoden daherkam.
Die Blue hat es tatsächlich noch über ein parametrisiertes System aber sehr
wohl und natürlich unter der Ausnutzung der Möglichkeit sehr viele Computerspiele
zu analysieren geschafft.
Im Prinzip könnte man eigentlich genau bei Die Blue und AlphaGo den Übergang festmachen.
Ja also dein Beispiel hat jetzt nicht hundertprozentig gestochen,
aber du hast natürlich vollkommen recht, dass die Vorgehensweise so ist und
selbstverständlich wird es auch KI basierte,
also jetzt Machine Learning basierte Schachsysteme geben und die werden wahrscheinlich
sogar noch besser funktionieren als die Blue,
nur konkret die Bloop selber war kurz davor und hat im Prinzip nochmal gezeigt,
was sagen wir mal auch mit den klassischen Methoden noch zu erzielen war.
Ja, und hat dann quasi das neue Zeitalter eingeleitet,
aber Go wiederum ist nochmal sehr viel komplexer als Schach und hat nochmal
sehr viel mehr Varianten und was vielleicht ein interessanter Punkt ist,
bei Die Blue, wenn ich das jetzt noch richtig erinnere, da kam quasi
sehr guter schachspieler bei heraus also das system konnte sehr gut schachspielen
so wie auch alle anderen gespielt haben bei alfa go war es so dass das mir jetzt
also ich habe auch keine ahnung von go ja aber so das ist das ist das auch noch
anders gespielt hat genau das ist nämlich komplett andere strategien die so
noch nie gesehen wurden.
Aber die hat es halt irgendwann in den Spielen gegen sich selber entwickelt.
Genau, also das ist natürlich das Gute daran ist an diesen Spielen,
die sind klar zu bewerten am Schluss ob es erfolgreich war oder nicht,
weil du hast halt gewonnen oder nicht, deswegen sind die sehr gut trainierbar
und da kann sich so ein System super dran schärfen.
Bei den ganzen anderen Aufgaben ist ja diffus, beim Bild gibt's kein richtig
oder falsch, das liegt dann ja im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes im Auge des Betrachters.
Und dann kann man auch in diese Refinement Zyklen gehen, die wir vorhin schon
besprochen hatten, mit Journey oder sowas.
Dann bist du sozusagen selbst derjenige, vielleicht zusammen mit so einer kleinen
Chat Community, die hier sagt so ja, im Prinzip richtig, aber hier könntest du nochmal beigehen.
Und da konnten sich aber diese Algorithmen definitiv schärfen.
Hier steht in dem Wikipedia-Artikel zu Deep Blue, die Schachsoftware war in
C geschrieben und lief unter dem Betriebssystem AIX 2.4,
sie berechnete je nach Stellungstyp zwischen 100 und 200 Millionen,
im Durchschnitt 126 Millionen Stellungen pro Sekunde.
Das heißt, das Ding hat wirklich einfach alle potenziell vielversprechenden
Pfade wirklich ausgerechnet.
Und genau das macht AlphaGo nicht. Sondern das ist eben ein Galtonbrett,
wo du eine Stellung reinwirfst und der wirft einen Zug raus.
Und wie der darauf kommt oder so, ist nicht mehr nachvollziehbar.
Es ist einfach nur in den Verbindungen, quasi in dem Feintuning dieser Nägelchen,
wann unter welchen Bedingungen die Kugel eher nach links oder nach rechts fällt.
Und deswegen ist auch das Output nicht deterministisch.
Und deswegen kannst du den können die dinger ist es halt schwierig zu zu,
Was sie überhaupt gelernt haben. Und deswegen ist es so überraschend, was sie tun.
Aber was sie gelernt haben, ist auf jeden Fall ein Produkt des Lernprozesses.
Und deswegen finde ich halt dieses Lernende Systeme einfach viel,
viel bessere Bezeichnung als, das ist jetzt künstliche Intelligenz.
Und natürlich liefert dir ChatGPT irrsinnige Ergebnisse.
Und ich find's aber noch irrer, wie irre die sind, wenn man sich überlegt,
womit man das Ding dahin trainiert hat.
Dass du einfach da Texte reingekippt hast. Was natürlich alle drin haben,
ist halt irgendwie Wikipedia.
Wikipedia ist so einer der Standard-Lehr-Datensätze für jedes LLM.
Und naja, jetzt haben wir eine lange Rede kurzer Sinn.
Es wird halt das Lernen eines menschlichen Gehirns nachgebaut durch mathematische Methoden,
die im Ergebnis eine Stärkung oder Schwächung von Verbindungen sind.
Und was du da irgendwann runterlädst, ist einfach echt ja die die Neuronen und
die Verbindungen dazwischen.
Das ist das Modell kannst du dir auch wenn du solche Modelle untersuchst,
kannst du dir anzeigen lassen.
Es steht dann drin Ja, das Modell hat was weiß ich so und so viele Layer in
dem Layer, in dem Layer 1 sind so und so viele Neurone, in dem anderen sind
so und so viele dazwischen sind so und so viele Verbindungen und dann steht
da einfach nur drin, wie stark jede Verbindung ist.
Und dann gibt es halt einen Input, dann führst du da rein als Vektor und dann
kommt ein Vektor, Vektor, ein Input als Vektor raus.
Und das so simpel ist das. Du machst so groß genug und dann kann das Ding auf
einmal sprechen. In allen Sprachen. Schon ganz geil.
Das ist wirklich super beeindruckende Technologie. Zur Begrifflichkeit würde
ich gerne noch eins sagen.
Wir haben ja das Problem im Deutschen, dass das Wort Intelligence in seiner
Vielfalt, in der es im Englischen steht, so im Deutschen nicht benutzt wird.
Wenn wir von Intelligenz reden, meinen wir damit im Prinzip immer die Fähigkeit
eines Gehirns oder eines Menschen sozusagen grundsätzlich in der Lage zu sein
bestimmte komplexe Aufgaben zu lösen oder vielleicht auch Kreativität zu entfalten.
Da könnte man sich schon drüber streiten, aber unsere Wahrnehmung ist explizit
so eine Eigenschaft eines Menschen.
Mit einem Psychologen einfach mal ganz kurz eine ad hoc Definition von Intelligenz zu postulieren.
Jetzt musst du mich mal ausreden lassen, Dinos, ich will ja auf was hinaus.
Der Punkt ist, der Begriff Intelligence im Englischen hat noch ganz andere Vektoren,
die meiner Meinung nach hier viel wichtiger sind.
Ja also wenn wir von künstlicher Intelligenz reden, dann ist das eigentlich
die falsche Übersetzung meiner Auffassung nach.
Artificial Intelligence ist halt mehr eine künstliche, ich sag mal Information.
Intelligenz ist ja auch das, was einen Geheimdienst macht. Also der Vorgang
des Einsammelns von Informationen, des Weiterleitens von Nachrichten,
das ist alles Intelligence.
Das hat nichts mit der Eigenschaft Intelligenz eines Hirnes zu tun,
sondern das ist konkret einfach der Vorgang, Sammeln von Informationen und diese
Informationen in irgendeiner Form sinnvoll zusammenzufügen.
Das was ein Geheimdienst oder ein Nachrichtendienst tut, das ist sozusagen deren Aufgabe.
Die sammeln aus vielen Quellen was zusammen und die Erwartung der Regierung
ist natürlich, dass so ein Geheimdienst dann sinnvolle Zusammenfassungen und
Einschätzungen liefern, was wird passieren. Wird ein Krieg ausbrechen?
Wird uns jemand angreifen?
Wie verhält sich die Wirtschaft? Etc. Gibt es irgendwelche Aktivitäten,
die wir zwar irgendwo beobachten, aber wir können uns keine Reimen drauf machen.
Und das ist ja im Prinzip die ganze Zeit das Problem bei der Bewertung der Gegenwart,
aber vor allem natürlich auch der Zukunft, dass wir Schwierigkeiten haben,
all die Signale, von denen wir umgeben sind, korrekt einzuordnen und zu den
richtigen Schlüssen zu kommen.
Später sagt man dann immer so, das war doch ganz offensichtlich,
hier da und da war ja überall sichtbar.
Aber es sind halt noch viele andere Sachen auch sichtbar gewesen,
nur die Gewichtung, was davon jetzt in welcher Form dazu führen wird,
dass irgendein Prozess in Gang gesetzt wird oder nicht, das ist halt der schwierige Teil.
Und insofern haben wir jetzt mit Artificial Intelligence einfach eine Computertechnologie erfunden,
nennen wir sie Machine Learning, weil sie im Wesentlichen auf Learning basiert,
aber ich würde sogar noch einen Schritt weiter gehen und sagen,
gerade die Tools des letzten Jahres,
also die Chat basierten Systeme, all diese Generatoren, die Large Language Models,
diese ganze Gruppe von verschiedenen Systemen, die sicherlich in der nächsten
Zeit schnell noch anwachsen wird.
Die sind jetzt sozusagen so das neue Rüstzeug und so wie wir uns dran gewöhnen mussten,
dass Computer schnell rechnen können und deswegen bestimmte Dinge tun können,
ja das hat ja auch eine Weile gedauert bis das bei uns so richtig eingesackt
ist und bis wir gecheckt haben was Kommunikation in dem Zusammenhang nochmal bewirkt.
Genauso müssen wir uns jetzt dran gewöhnen, dass wir eben Software-Technologien
haben, die in der Lage sind, aus einem diffusen Eingangsbild Schlüsse zu ziehen
auf Basis von vorher schon gewonnenem Wissen. Und das ist einfach auch nichts Schlechtes.
Das ist eine tolle Technik, mit der man eine Menge gute Sachen machen kann,
aber natürlich, wie wir alle wissen, auch eine Menge Unfug anstellen kann.
Ich glaube dass du dich an einer stelle verrannt hast und zwar also alles was
du gerade richtig eine sache die ich glaube ich so nicht so haltbar ist dass
der begriff intelligence,
eine andere Bedeutung hat, ist korrekt. Dass deswegen aber Artificial Intelligence
eine andere Bedeutung hätte, ist nicht korrekt.
Also der Artificial Intelligence-Bereich meint genau die gleiche Intelligenz,
die wir als Menschen als menschliche Intelligenz wahrnehmen oder bezeichnen.
Also kognitive Fähigkeiten. Du hast ja gerade so gesagt, Intelligence ist auch
Wissen. Es gibt unterschiedliche Bedeutungen des Begriffs Intelligenz.
Ich Ich glaube aber nicht, dass der Begriff künstliche Intelligenz eine schlechte
Übersetzung eines besseren amerikanischen oder englischen Begriffs ist,
weil der ist genau der gleiche.
Lernen, Abwägen, Selbstkorrektur, Kreativität, all das was du halt unter naiv
menschlicher Intelligenz auch zusammenfasst, ist damit auch gemeint.
Gut, kann man drüber streiten, es deckt das sicherlich mit ab,
aber ich wollte ja nun explizit darauf hinaus, dass man das als Werkzeug versteht.
Und in dem Sinne ist es ein Werkzeug, um Intelligence durchzuführen, ja? Mit Künstlichkeit.
Und das Spannende ist eigentlich, das haben wir schon gesagt,
ich versteige mich jetzt nicht in einer Diskussion darüber, was Intelligenz
ist, aber sicherlich ist Lernen eine absolute notwendige Bedingung von etwas, das Intelligenz ist.
Dass es lernfähig ist. Wenn man irgendetwas Intelligenz attestieren möchte oder
kann, dann wird und muss es lernfähig sein.
Und ich glaube, dass ein großer Teil der Debatte um die sogenannte künstliche Intelligenz,
sinnvoller geführt werden kann, wenn die Menschen sich das immer vor Augen halten.
Es ist etwas Lernendes oder Selbstlernendes.
Und was es lernt, bestimmen immer noch die Menschen, die es trainieren,
die das Lernmaterial bereitstellen.
Und nur wenn man ausreichend Lernmaterial hat und ausreichend komplexe Probleme,
dann hat man überhaupt einen Anwendungsfall.
Und deswegen meine ich das mit dem Überschätzt und Unterschätzt,
weil man teilweise davon ausgeht, künstliche Intelligenz wird jetzt irgendwas
erfinden und die Menschheit unterdrücken oder so.
Das dauert noch ein bisschen. Da müssen wir einfach noch viel mehr Lernmaterial schaffen.
Das machen wir ja gerade mit den ganzen Kriegen und Konflikten.
Aber noch glaube ich, sind wir nicht so weit, dass ein selbstlernendes System uns vernichten wird.
Oder denkst du? Nee, das kriegen wir selber besser hin.
Stimmt, da sind wir noch, also da können wir wirklich sagen,
da sind wir der Maschine auf jeden Fall noch überlegen, ne?
Jetzt, aber worauf ich eigentlich hinaus will, oder was ich eigentlich als Anlass
für dieses Thema genommen habe, jetzt kommt das in die Welt, ne?
Und jetzt ist, ich glaube es ist so eine Situation von, wenn der Wind des Wandels
weht, bauen die einen Windmühlen und die anderen Schutzmauern.
Und das Thema überschätzt und unterschätzt gleichermaßen und jetzt stehen da
alle und schreien um die Wette, wer jetzt als nächstes arbeitslos wird.
Was glaubst du, wer als nächstes arbeitslos wird?
Durch künstliche Intelligenz.
Was ich glaube was wirklich ist oder was geglaubt wird was es sei?
Beides. Arbeitslos.
Also ehrlich gesagt ich sehe generell wenn
ich das jetzt mal seriös beantworten soll und das jetzt kein versteckter Witz
war hab ich da gar keine großen Bedenken was vor allem jetzt erstmal wegfallen
wird sind Leute oder Tätigkeiten die Leute fallen nicht weg aber die Tätigkeiten,
die ohne größere Anstrengungen so klein klein durchgeführt werden.
Man hat ja gesehen wozu die Systeme heutzutage in der Lage sind,
das heißt sie können irgendwie schnell mal Texte machen, es gibt Leute die bieten
solche Dienstleistungen an dir mal einen Brief zu schreiben oder so etwas.
Gibt's ja auch diesen schönen Begriff des mechanischen Türken, Mechanical Turk.
Und es gibt ja auch viele Systeme im Internet, wo du mal schnell mal,
ich brauch mal ein Logo, ich brauch mal hier jemand der mir ein Bild freistellen kann und sowas,
sowas konnte man irgendwie kaufen für einen Dollar und dann hat sich tatsächlich
irgendjemand in, keine Ahnung wo, wo in Asien vielleicht hingesetzt,
hat das Bild genommen, hat das Bild freigestellt und dann ist da so eine Mikrotransaktion
über den Teich gelaufen.
Und jetzt kannst du halt dein Bildbearbeitungsprogramm of choice hochholen und
sagst stell mal frei und nicht nur,
dass das Freistellen als solches super ist, er weiß auch sofort was freigestellt werden soll,
weil er einfach, seit ewig, seit über ein Jahrzehnt oder seit es Photoshop gibt,
war so dieses Problem von freistehende Haare vor Hintergrund,
wie kriegst du die isoliert.
Totaler Albtraum und es gab Leute, die konnten das besonders gut und andere
vielleicht nicht so gut und manche haben sich vielleicht darauf spezialisiert
und das sind so tatsächlich solche Dienstleistungen, so kleinen kleinen Dienstleistungen,
die jetzt in zunehmendem Maße von Software Tools abgelöst werden können.
Aber das ist letzten Endes kein Vorgang, der nicht auch schon vor zehn und zwanzig
und vor dreißig Jahren stattgefunden hat in anderen Bereichen.
Ich komme noch aus einer Zeit, da war so Schriftsatz noch ein richtiger Aufwand,
als ich das erste Mal angefangen habe, irgendwelche Firmen zu beraten,
so Werbeagenturen oder so, da saßen die da also wirklich noch und haben einen
riesigen Aufwand gemacht, um einfach Text auf eine Seite zu bekommen.
Und das war halt dann so ein bisschen die Zeitgeburt des Desktop Publishing etc.
Und irgendwann war das so vollkommen normal, eben mal so einen Text und mit
ordentlichem Font gerendert auf so eine Seite in druckbarer Vorlage zu erzeugen.
Und das sind alles solche technologischen Schritte, die dann natürlich Textsetzer
und so spezialisierte Berufe in dem Moment ausgelöst haben, die aber dann,
wo die Leute dann aber mit ihrer Expertise
Diese darüber zu wissen wie sieht Text gut aus auch mit den neuen Werkzeugen
im Prinzip weiterarbeiten können und deswegen kann ich auch so diese Befürchtung
mit oh Gott die Grafiker werden jetzt arbeitslos.
Nee, die Grafiker kriegen jetzt andere Werkzeuge und bestimmte Dinge die heute
noch in Auftrag waren sind jetzt vielleicht keiner mehr aber dafür ist sehr
viel mehr die kreative Hoheit über dieses Produkt erforderlich,
weil klar kannst du jetzt mit nem Prompt irgendwie Dalli 3 und wie sie alle
heißen dazu bringen tolle Bilder zu erzeugen aber erstens basiert das alles
auch nur auf Vorwissen, haben wir ja schon diskutiert und andererseits bedeutet
das ja noch lange nicht, dass du eine gute Idee hast.
Ja also gerade mit solchen Werkzeugen können Leute,
die ein gutes kreatives Denken haben,
also die im Prinzip erstmal diesen ersten Schritt gut können,
die dann vielleicht auch in der Lage sind mit ihren Werkzeugen das auch gut
umzusetzen, aber deren eigentliche Leistung ja, dass das erschaffen ist.
Also alle meine Logos zum Beispiel, die hier bei der Metaebene für diese Podcast entstanden sind,
das hat der Sven ganz viele gemacht und Sven ist ein super Grafiker und ein schneller Arbeiter,
aber die eigentliche Begeisterung, die bei mir immer aufkam war die Idee erstmal
zu haben, für die einzelnen Motive.
Freak Show Logo zum Beispiel ist einfach fantastisch. Guckt euch mal das Logo
mal genau an, was da drin steckt.
Da kann dir natürlich so ein KI System super dabei helfen, schnell mal noch
sehr viel mehr Varianten zu machen, viel größeren Suchraum aufzumachen,
um auf gute Ideen zu kommen.
Am Ende zählt dann sozusagen das Durchexerzieren eines Gedankens und von daher
sehe ich da nicht so viele Probleme.
Dinge werden sich ändern, Berufe werden sich ändern, sie werden aber eher woanders
hin transformieren, da wo es eben nicht wegmechanisiert werden kann.
Und jetzt geht aber, also die aktuelle Diskussion, die geht ja jetzt im Prinzip
genau da weiter, dass sie sagt, ja, aber was, wenn das jetzt auf einmal alle Bereiche berührt?
Und das, was du jetzt gerade über Grafiker gesagt hast und über Textsetzer,
das war ja der, sag mal, der Vorteil war, das hat dann, ja, das hat dann mal
so einen Bereich betroffen.
Also Textsetzer, das war jetzt keine tragende, kein großer Teil der Gesellschaft,
der davon betroffen war.
Und die Diskussion, die jetzt gerade geführt wird, ist so ungefähr,
ja, aber Moment mal, das Ding kann geile Bilder malen, das kann besser malen
als ich, das kann besser schreiben als ich.
Was ist, wenn das jetzt morgen meinen Job besser machen kann als ich?
Und dann gibt es natürlich diesen sehr schönen Satz, ich weiß gar nicht,
AI wird dich nicht ersetzen, aber jemand der AI benutzt auf jeden Fall.
Also irgendwie so eine, ihr müsst diese neue Technologie jetzt anwenden,
um genau wie du sagst, euch zu freuen, was ihr alles nicht mehr machen müsst,
um die Ergebnisse zu generieren, die schon in eurem Kopf sind.
Oder die Ideen zu realisieren.
Aber deswegen habe ich gerade so ein bisschen versucht, darüber zu sprechen,
was für Probleme sind geeignet, dass sie von dem Ding jetzt oder von dieser
Technologie bald gelöst werden oder besser angegangen werden,
weil es eben nicht alle sind.
Also für nicht alle Bereiche haben wir die Voraussetzungen, dass man jetzt mit
maschinellem Lernen dort zu einem Durchbruch kommt, den man nicht schon hatte.
Programmieren ist aber leider auch einer, also ich meine, das ist schon.
Aber auch beim Programmieren ist es so, du kannst dir von diesen Systemen extrem
helfen lassen, also hier diese ganzen Copilot Systeme etc.
Die helfen beim Programmieren, aber es hilft dir alles überhaupt nichts,
wenn du nach wie vor keine Ahnung hast vom Programmieren. Ja, äh...
Also ich sag mal, da glaube ich, das wird sich halt relativ zügig noch klären.
Es wird Sachen geben, wo Programmieren auf einmal nicht mehr notwendig wird,
weil du Dinge auf einmal zum Leben bringen kannst, automatisieren lassen kannst,
du kannst halt die Module ansprechen und kannst sagen ich möchte gerne,
dass dieses Modul Daten erzeugt, dass dieses Modul einlässt etc.
Super, ich meine da muss sich, ich meine wir haben sowieso viel zu wenig Programmierer,
um die Aufgaben zu stemmen, die heutzutage schon anliegen, also das ist ja ein
Bereich, der muss wegkratzen, wir haben zu viele schlechte Programmierer,
die sich dann darum kümmern und dann kommt halt so ein Quatschball raus,
also insofern bin ich da sehr froh,
Wenn das sich wieder mal auf die Leute reduziert, die eben auch wissen was sie
tun, die dann eben auf einem höheren Level arbeiten können.
Die dann mit diesen KI Systemen zum Beispiel arbeiten, das wirst du ja auch kennen.
In der Security ist das ja ein riesen Ding.
Also gerade diese Anforderung aus diffusen Informationen Schlüsse zu ziehen
ist ja im Prinzip genau das was du machen musst, wenn du irgendwie monitoren
musst, ob du jetzt gerade irgendeine Hackerattacke unterlegst.
Das sind ja im Prinzip genau solche Systeme und dann kann man damit halt besser
auch verteidigen. Klar man kann damit vielleicht auch besser Fehler finden und
dann auch besser angreifen.
Das ist natürlich hier wieder so eine Aufrüstung auf beiden Seiten.
Aber im Prinzip die Leute,
die sowieso wissen, was eigentlich überwacht werden müsste und worauf man achten
muss oder was man im Prinzip alles heranziehen kann, um eine Bewertung zu machen,
die können dann solche Werkzeuge nehmen und die dann eben auch richtig einsetzen.
Aber dazu musst du halt auch nach wie vor eine Vorstellung davon haben,
was ist Security, was ist überhaupt hier meine Systeme, was kann ich überhaupt
davon betroffen sein, worauf muss man sich vielleicht einstellen.
Also ich hab da nicht so eine Angst davor ehrlich gesagt. Ich sehe eher unseren,
im Bereich Fake News etc. also was uns jetzt schon seit längerer Zeit plagt,
das Erzeugen von gefälschten Videos.
Gefälschten Fotos, von gefälschten Audioaufnahmen. Es ist mittlerweile ohne
weiteres möglich Stimmen nachzuäffnen.
Das ist ja jetzt auch schon ein paar mal aufgekommen. Noch hatten wir nicht den großen Knall,
aber ich glaube das wird nicht mehr lange dauern und wir werden irgend so eine
Sache erleben, wo irgendeine wichtige Person angeblich irgendwas gesagt hat.
Und ein Video geht rum und alle glauben das und ein Krieg bricht aus und es
war aber alles nur gefaked.
Ich glaube eher, also meine größere Sorge ist, also den Fall werden wir sicherlich
irgendwann mal haben, in groß oder klein, hoffentlich jetzt nicht noch ein Krieg,
also das wird langsam auch zu viel.
Kann aber passieren.
Weil ich könnte mir vorstellen, mindestens genauso wahrscheinlich halte ich,
dass irgendjemand etwas sagt und es nicht geglaubt wird, dass es echt ist.
Das ist dann die nächste Stufe. Das ist ja alles Fake, das ist ja Trumps Dauerargument.
Wenn irgendwas nicht passt, dann ist es halt Fake.
Genau aus dem Grund komme ich darauf, dass ich glaube, das ist der wahrscheinlichere
Fall, weil wir gerade mehr Realitätsverweigerungen als Faktentreue bei den Durchgeknallten haben.
Also mehr Realitätsverweigerungen als Faktentreue.
Ich halte den Fall für wahrscheinlicher, dass irgendjemand etwas sagt und keiner
glaubt, dass das das nächste große Problem ist, als dass jemand etwas nicht
sagt, Aber alle glauben er hätte es gesagt.
Einfach weil die Bekloppten gerade eher auf der Realitätsverweigerungsschiene
sind als auf der, ich muss jetzt hier genau gucken was jemand gesagt hat Schiene.
Die glauben ja eh jeden Scheiß.
Und alles mögliche nicht. Aber okay das ist eine philosophische Überlegung was
das nächste Problem ist.
Also du blickst positiv in die Zukunft.
Wir haben auf jeden Fall ja schon mal unseren Exit geplant hier.
Wir lassen uns bald durch ChatGPT ersetzen.
Das ist vor allem in unserem Fall sehr gut möglich, weil wir ja halt auch keine perfekte KI brauchen.
Reicht ja, wenn ihr alle 10 Minuten mal irgendeinen völligen Stoß redet.
Ist das eigentlich ein Qualitätskriterium im Nachbau von uns.
Ich hab natürlich drüber nachgedacht, wie gut könnte jetzt eine KI so ein Podcast machen.
Gibt natürlich schon die ersten Leute, die sowas gemacht haben.
Hier der erste KI generierte Podcast und so.
Am Anfang haben wir ja auch so, mach mal eine Eröffnungsrede und so.
Ja, Noah, das ist halt das Ding. Klar, du wirst damit ein Wettbewerb sein.
Wirst du glaube ich sehr gut automatisieren können also du wirst diesen Radioslot
wo der Wetterbericht vorgelesen wird der ist so generisch und der ist irgendwie so klar und gleich.
Das hier habe ich für dich im Internet gefunden.
Also ich hab das Wetterbericht schon, das ist eine der wenigen Sachen, die ich mir.
Genau, aber halt auch so in diesem Konversationsmodell mit zwei Leuten,
die sich die Bälle zuwerfen, weil sie sowieso immer die gleichen Witze machen
und vieles, gerade im medialen Bereich, hat ja so einen Standardpattern.
Macht das dann irgendwann neue Witze?
Wenn wir jetzt eine KI nehmen, vielleicht gibt es dann irgendwann neue Witze
in unserem eigenen Podcast, Tim.
Witze, die sich noch keiner vorher ausgedacht hat.
Das glaube ich halt nicht.
Meinst du?
Ja, also das sind keine guten Witze.
Also für einen guten Witz. Und vor allem, das Ding ist ja auch, gerade,
ist ja nun der Grund der Zuwendung primär darin zu finden, dass da was originäres,
menschliches, nahbares kommt.
Jetzt können natürlich alle Leute uns sagen, ja aber hier YouTube und Instagram
vor allem ist ja voll mit diesen gefakten Identitäten, mit diesen ganzen KI-Influencern.
Das ist auch ganz interessant, ich hab da nicht viel Zeit mit verbracht,
aber ich weiß, dass es das gibt.
Da gibt's halt wirklich vollständig generierte Videos von irgendwie,
was weiß ich, hübschen Manga Mädchen, die irgendwie aus ihrem Leben erzählen, die es nicht gibt.
Die also wirklich komplett mit videogenerierenden Tools erzeugt werden und dann
halt so Follower haben und Leute, die damit interagieren.
So ein bisschen wie Sexpuppen, das ist ja auch so ein Phänomen,
dass Leute sich dann so eine Puppe kaufen und dann heiraten und sich aufs Sofa setzen.
Es gibt auch Leute, die glauben, denen ist das glaube ich auch irgendwie alles ein bisschen egal.
Also die wollen einfach nur dran glauben können und tun's dann auch gerne,
wenn sich das dann ausreichend bequem gestaltet und die eigenen Wünsche oder
die eigenen Vorstellungen ausreichend abdeckt.
Und dann ist es ihnen dann auch wirklich egal. Gott sei Dank ist das nicht die
Zuhörerschaft von Logbuch-Netzpolitik.
Hoffe ich.
Ja das ist so ein Ding, wo ich mir denken könnte, auch das ist so eine Gefährdung
im Sinne von so einer emotionalen Gefährdung.
Gibt's da so einen Film Hör, hast du den gesehen? Ja, der davon handelt.
Richtig, stimmt. Tatsächlich ist das genau das Motiv.
Und das ist auch ein hervorragender Film. Falls ihr den nicht gesehen habt,
schaut euch den an. Das ist einer der Filme, die, glaube ich,
die diese Zeit, die wir jetzt haben, ganz gut eingeleitet hat.
Ich habe natürlich, aber da wird es dann jetzt wirklich ewig dauern,
das noch zu diskutieren.
Von einigen wird diese Entwicklung, die wir da jetzt gerade sehen,
als die vierte große Kränkung der Menschheit gesehen.
Also die erste, Moment, Galileo sagt hier, pass mal auf, Erde ist gar nicht
der Mittelpunkt des Universums.
Dann Darwin sagt, wir stampfen von dem Affen ab.
Und Freud sagt, hier sind einfach nur alle triebgesteuert und das,
was ihr euch dazu rationalisiert, ist im Prinzip alles nur so ein paar Komplexe,
weil ihr irgendwie mit eurer Mutter nicht klarkommt.
Und die Werden so behandelt und übrigens Freud hat in dieser Reihe überhaupt
nichts verloren, weil es einfach nur komplett esoterischer Quatsch ist, aber okay.
Hat zu seiner Zeit ein paar Leute weitergebracht im Verständnis ihrer selbst,
aber es ist keine Wissenschaft, auch keine Entzauerung der Menschheit.
Und dann eben jetzt, und dann kommen aber die Kränkungen der Menschheit ihrer
selbst durch die Maschinen, die sie baut.
So zumindest die Geschichte.
Und wenn ich darüber nachdenke, glaube ich, es ist weniger so,
dass wir gerade übertrumpft werden, aber dass uns vielleicht auch ein bisschen
die Banalität von dem, was unser Leben ausmacht, so ein bisschen vor Augen geführt wird.
Dass man das generieren kann, Texte.
Und dass vieles, wofür wir viel Zeit aufgebracht haben, simpel erlernbar und abbildbar ist.
Die fast viel größere Kränkung, die auch zum Beispiel in diesem Film Hör eben dargestellt wird.
Wo das Hör, der Film handelt ja davon, dass ein Mann mit einer AI-Begleiterin,
dass er sich in die verliebt.
Und das zeigt ja im Prinzip auch die Banalität unserer Emotionen auf eine Weise.
Dass du, dass da jemand nur ein paar nette Sachen sagen muss und einfühlsam
ist und dann funktioniert das. Das
ist etwas, was Psychotherapeutinnen und Therapeuten lernen und trainieren.
Das ist deren Job, Beziehungen mit Menschen einzugehen und deren Emotionen dahin
zu steuern, dass die sich irgendwie bereit fühlen, über bestimmte Dinge zu reden
oder die zu reflektieren oder bestimmte Einsichten zu bringen.
Das geht, das funktioniert. Das heißt, wir sind gar nicht so geheimnisvoll und
irre und einzigartig, wie wir uns gefühlt haben.
Das könnte ich mir vorstellen, was da so diese Dekränkung ist.
Und vielleicht ganz kurz noch, es gibt in der in der Psychologie das irre Phänomen,
das wird auch bei den ganzen Machine Learnern die ganze Zeit,
der kluge Hans. Kennst du den klugen Hans? Das war ein Pferd.
Kluge Hans war ein Pferd. Und der kluge Hans konnte zählen.
Der Eigentümer für den Klugen Hans hat den da irgendwie hingestellt,
dann stand vor dem Pferd so ein Brett,
wo das mit dem Huf draufhauen konnte und dann haben die die Tafel hingehalten,
eine Zahl drauf gemalt und dann hat das Pferd genauso oft geklopft,
bis es bei dieser Zahl angelangt war.
Ja, dann hast du eine 5, dann hat das Pferd 5 mal geklopft. 10,
dann hat das Pferd 10 mal geklopft.
Und das wurde natürlich auch in Zweifel gestellt von vielen,
ja, aber es hat eigentlich, es hat funktioniert und es hat...
Gut funktioniert, wenn der Eigentümer nicht dabei war. Wenn ich die Geschichte
jetzt richtig erinnere.
Aber es funktionierte nicht mehr so gut, sodass man irgendwann auf den Trichter kam.
Also der Mann war kein Betrüger, er war auch selber davon überzeugt,
dass er seinem Pferd das Zählen beigebracht hat.
Was dann sich durch Experimente herausgestellt hat,
ist, dass dieses Pferd gelernt hatte, Menschen sehr genau zu beobachten und
einfach dann aufzuhören, wenn die dieses komische Zeichen machen,
was sie halt machen, wenn du, wenn das Pferd die richtige Zahl getippt hat.
Und dann wurde, aber jetzt ist die Konsequenz, die Überlegung daraus ist,
haben die jetzt, war das ein doofes Pferd oder hatte das vielleicht viel größere kognitive Leistungen,
weil es einen Skill gelernt hat, der ihm als Pferd nun wirklich nicht gegeben
war und auch nicht notwendig war oder nicht angeboren war,
den es wirklich gelernt hat, nämlich Menschen so genau auf nonverbale Signale von,
oh jetzt ist er, jetzt gleich ist er da, jetzt ist er da, krass,
oh bloß nicht weiter tippen, dass das Pferd das, diese minimalen Wahrnehmungen
hatte oder diese minimalen Zeichen wahrgenommen hat, die Menschen nicht wahrgenommen.
Weil zu zählen ist für das Pferd ja völlig, also absoluter Quatsch,
warum soll es Zahlen lernen?
Also war das nicht eigentlich sogar schwerer, die Leistung, die das Pferd da
vollbracht hat, als das blöde Zahlensystem zu lernen, was die Menschen sich da ausgedacht haben.
Das fand ich, finde ich ein schönes Beispiel dafür, was erstens diese Modelle
vielleicht in Wirklichkeit lernen, vielleicht was ganz anderes,
aber sie simulieren, es kommt etwas anderes dabei raus.
Also die Leute dachten, das Pferd kann zählen. Es hat in Wirklichkeit etwas
ganz anderes gelernt. Und die Frage ist, ist das jetzt klüger oder weniger klug gewesen. Finde ich.
Wirklich eine faszinierende historische Situation, in der sehr viel steckt über
Intelligenz und über auch das, was Menschen sich vielleicht einfach auf sich selber einbilden.
Das Pferd genau das gleiche gemacht wie jetzt diese Machine Learning Systeme.
Also auch die kleinsten Signale waren hier sozusagen in der Lage ein bestimmtes Verhalten zu triggern.
Signale die man so vielleicht erstmal selbst nie so aufgenommen hat.
So könnte man ja im Prinzip auch selber gut rechnen.
Solange es sich allerdings alles in einem Aufgabenraum befindet,
wo die ganzen Beobachter, die ich beobachte, das auch können.
Weil wenn die das nicht können, dann kann ich denen auch nichts ansehen.
Ja naja, der Kluge Hans, super Phänomen habe ich jetzt schon relativ viel aus
unserem Vortrag verraten.
Worauf wollen wir hinaus?
Ah ja genau, also die, das ist ja jetzt eine Gefahr für den Arbeitsmarkt und
für die Gesellschaft und deswegen muss das reguliert werden.
Die Pferde nehmen uns die Taschenrechner weg.
Und es gibt ja, die wollen ja tatsächlich eine KI-Verordnung machen.
Und da geht es dann aber zum Beispiel um, das haben wir auch hier behandelt
damals, das Amazon hat so eine KI trainiert, die haben im Prinzip die Bewerbung genommen.
Die haben eingehende Bewerbungen gehabt und dann haben sie nachher geguckt,
okay, wer sind denn die Leute, die am Ende bei uns Jobs bekommen?
Dann haben sie einfach, das ist ja auch, dann hast du wieder viele, viele Daten.
Dann lernst du, trainierst du mit einem neuronalen Modell, das sagt dann irgendwie,
alles klar, hier alle Bewerbungen rein und am Ende weißt du ja,
wer hat am Ende einen Job bekommen. Das hast du ja quasi digital vorliegen.
Das heißt, da hat eine große Menge gut gelabelt.
Das Problem, nämlich wen stellen wir hier an und wen nicht? Kann man vielleicht
an der Hand der high-Ring-KI schon Vorhersagen treffen, damit wir bessere Vorstellungsgespräche führen?
Vielleicht können wir der KI ja irgendwas beibringen, was wir in den Vorstellungsgesprächen,
was wir nicht sehen, aber die KI sieht es.
Und die Hoffnung war dann, dann hat man mehr Vorstellungsgespräche mit Leuten,
die man am Ende auch nimmt und weniger Vorstellungsgespräche mit Leuten,
die man nicht nimmt und hat damit einen besseren High-Ring-Prozess.
Und dann haben sie sich überlegt, ja, es wäre auf jeden Fall schlecht,
wenn diese KI jetzt zum Beispiel gegen Frauen diskriminiert oder gegen Menschen
bestimmter Hintergründe oder so.
Also nehmen wir diese Information raus, die geben wir dem einfach nicht.
Dann lernt er das bestimmt nicht.
Am Ende war aber diese KI, die sie da hatten, halt sexistisch.
Warum war sie es? Naja, weil die High-Ring-Abteilung von Amazon sexistisch war
Und der Bias halt in den Daten war.
Woran hat das Ding gesehen, wer Mann oder Frau ist, weiß der Geier.
Es hat es erkannt. Es hatte potenziell wahrscheinlich so,
erkennst du dann an den Hobbys oder an der Lücke im Lebenslauf oder an den Schulen,
an denen die Leute waren, ob sie aus welchen Bereichen der Stadt sie kommen.
Kommen sie aus den reichen Bereichen oder den armen.
Haben die sich nur Metadaten angeschaut oder auch Gesprächsprotokolle?
Ich glaube nur die Bewerbungen, weil die mussten das Ding ja auf Bewerbungen
trainieren, weil sie wollten ja eingehende Bewerbungen danach kategorisieren.
Okay, aber die Bewerbungen enthielten aber von denen selbst erstellten Text vermutlich.
Gehe ich von aus. Die konnten sie ja nicht mit Chat-GPT machen.
Genau und ich denke, dass du aber schon an der Sprache, an diesen Texten kannst
du wahrscheinlich schon zwischen Männern und Frauen unterscheiden,
welche Worte verwendet wer da so.
Da gibt es tausend Möglichkeiten, wir wissen es nicht, weil das Ding hat die
implizit gelernt, ja? Ergebnis war...
Mit den Amazon-Entscheidungen, die da getroffen wurden und jetzt war die sexistisch.
So, und dann hast du jetzt eine sexistische KI, was machst du?
Schaltest sie sofort ab und ersetzt sie natürlich einfach wieder durch normale,
lebendige Sexisten, weil das ist ja dann in Ordnung.
Genau das ist dann passiert. Oh nein. Und das ist jetzt auch das,
worüber wir gerade die ganze Zeit reden.
Wenn wir jetzt hier fehlerhafte Algorithmen haben und Fehler in den Daten und
dann haben wir hier Diskriminierung durch KI und am Ende muss es aber ein Mensch
entscheiden und so, da kommen dann irgendwie diese ganzen Ethiker,
die nicht damit klarkommen, dass jetzt eine Maschine die gleiche Entscheidung trifft.
Und ich finde das irgendwie lustig. Natürlich überspitze ich das jetzt auch
ironisch. Ich bin jetzt kein Freund davon, dass wir sofort alle möglichen Entscheidungen
durch Maschinen treffen lassen.
Insbesondere bei dem stumpfen Glauben, den viele Menschen haben.
Sobald der Computer sagt No, dann ist es eben auch No.
Und natürlich ist das gefährlich, solche Entscheidungssysteme zu bauen,
aber ich denke, zu sagen, am Ende muss ein Mensch die Entscheidung treffen,
ist wirklich nur die halbe Wahrheit. Das ist aber nicht die Lösung.
Der Mensch hat ja im Zweifelsfall, ist das der Rassist oder Sexist,
dessen Daten das Ding irgendwann mal trainiert haben.
Hilft genauso wenig wie ein Richterinnenvorbehalt bei allen möglichen Problemen.
Aber das sind das, worüber man sich gerade bei dem AI-Act so,
ja und KI ist gefährlich und wir möchten nicht, dass KI Entscheidungen über uns trifft.
Am Ende muss es ein Mensch sein. Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich die Debatten
sind, die am Ende mal relevant sein werden. Ich weiß es nicht.
Vielleicht sind sie es auch. Was denkst du?
Naja, ich meine, das interessante ist ja, dass sie der Meinung waren,
dass die Entscheidungen, die sie früher schon gefällt haben,
gute Entscheidungen waren.
Ja, genau.
Aber vielleicht haben sie sich einfach über Jahrzehnte nur totale Volltrottel
und irgendwie Selbstdarsteller und was weiß ich für Menschen eingetreten,
die gar nicht so die beste Wahl waren und dann haben sie sich sozusagen in ihrer
Vorstellung, wie sie ihr System trainieren müssen, davon leiten lassen,
dass ja früher schon immer alles super war und genauso soll es immer bleiben.
Also die Kriterien sind einfach die falschen gewesen. Mal ganz unabhängig von
irgendwelchen diskriminierenden Aspekten, weil natürlich diskriminierst du,
dass es genau das Richtige war.
Um eine Entscheidung zu fällen, um zwischen verschiedenen Leuten zu entscheiden,
wen du denn jetzt haben möchtest. Natürlich das ist Diskriminierung.
Nicht in einem negativen gesellschaftlichen Sinne, sondern in einem technischen Sinne.
Und du musst natürlich irgendwas heranziehen und ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen,
dass ein Trainingsmodell helfen kann.
Die eigentliche Frage ist, wie trainierst du das? Womit trainierst du das?
Was sind deine leitenden Elemente? Und so könntest du halt unter Umständen,
wenn du richtig trainierst, genau den gegenteiligen Effekt erzielen,
weil du auf einmal Dinge gewichtest, die vorher einfach von den ganzen Personalern
so nie gewichtet wurden.
Bloß wo man diese Wahrheiten herauszieht, das ist so eine Frage,
das sind aber alles Dinge, die müssen aber in den Daten sein,
ja genau, aber wenn sie da nicht drin sind,
dann hast du halt Pech, klar, aber vielleicht entstehen ja solche Daten irgendwie,
also wir stehen ja mit diesem ganzen Ding noch total am Anfang,
also ne, Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass es irgendwann mal was gibt,
was man mal in puncto KI vielleicht regulieren muss.
Kann sein. Aber ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass derzeit noch niemand eine Ahnung
hat, was das sein müsste. Weil das einfach alles noch viel zu schnell geht.
Wir werden jetzt, ich meine wir haben vor einem Jahr, da haben wir zwar schon
über Shitter gesprochen oder Twix, aber das...
Bestenfalls am Rande irgendwo. Das ging dann so gegen Ende des Jahres los.
Und seitdem kriegst du die Tür nicht zu mit dem Thema. Warum?
Absolut berechtigt, weil das wirklich eine Technologie ist, die einen Unterschied macht.
Also das ist echt so, KI ist quasi wie, ach das ist immer ein bisschen schwierig
mit diesen Vergleichen, aber KI ist würde ich sagen in der Kategorie Internet.
Also die Zeit vor dem Internet und nach dem Internet, da müssen wir auch nicht
lange drüber reden, das ist einfach komplett alles, alles ist auf einmal anders.
Und genau so ist das jetzt irgendwie mit KI. Und das ist wirklich so.
Also natürlich gibt's jetzt ja auch viel Hype und natürlich gibt's da eine ganze
Menge Leute, die jetzt auf diesem Hype-Train auch irgendwie abfeiern,
aber es ist jetzt nicht so ein Schwachsinn wie Blockchain, was wirklich der
größte … Alles geändert.
Ja scheiß hat das. Blockchain, warte mal ehrlich, jetzt sehen das doch alle oder?
Das das einfach alles nur Unsinn war? Nichts ist passiert. 15,
Jahre Gerede, Effekt null nada, zero, niente, ria und da sind wir jetzt.
Und jetzt hier irgendwie KI, this is the real thing. Da passiert was.
Da hat sich jetzt schon alles geändert.
Mein Workflow hat sich geändert. Ich arbeite damit laufend täglich.
Du wahrscheinlich auch oder? Mal ehrlich.
Kann ich jetzt nichts zu sagen. Naja ich tu das. Leute zu, mit denen ich arbeite.
Naja, ich meine, damit arbeiten, gerade, ich würde ja meinen im Security-Bereich,
also da habe ich schon viel von gehört, dass das ein richtiges Thema ist.
Aber davon mal abgesehen, was du machst, für meinen kreativen Prozess ist das
eine super Hilfe. Also vor allem.
Das Beispiel direkt hier aus unserem Dialog heraus. Du hast Bernoulli-Brett
gesagt und ich so Bernoulli-Brett.
Google irgendwie Bernoulli-Brett? Nee, weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung.
Chat-GPT gefragt? Kenne ich nicht, weiß ich nicht, gibt's nicht. Das ist mir so okay.
Chat-GPT weiß nicht, was ein Bernoulli-Brett ist. Hier ist doch was falsch.
Und dann habe ich kurz so deine Beschreibung eingegeben, ich kann auch kurz
sagen, was ich mal kurz eingetippt habe so nebenbei.
Ich hab da gesagt, wie nennt man die Verteilung von Kugeln, die ein Nagelbrett herunterfallen?
Venue-Verteilung. Das hab ich da reingemacht so. Und dann sagt er,
ah jetzt verstehe ich, wir sprechen von dem Galton-Brett, bla bla bla und so
weiter. San Francis Galton im 19.
Jahrhundert und so weiter. Ich hatte den Begriff nicht parat,
aber ich hätte den jetzt auch nicht so ohne weiter, also klar,
da hätte ich mich schon irgendwie ein bisschen durchgoogeln können,
nur ich musste jetzt wirklich nur einen Satz schreiben.
Und das ist einfach sehr hilfreich und vor allem sehr hilfreich,
um was zu finden, von dem man weiß, dass es existiert, aber man weiß verreckend
nicht, wie es heißt. Also dafür benutze ich das laufend.
Immer so dieses, ah was war das nochmal, wie hieß das nochmal,
oh scheiße, irgendwie, das war so, wo man das macht und das macht und das macht
und genau diesen, diesen fällt mir nicht mehr ein Effekt so,
das kann ich damit wunderbar abdecken, also für mich ist das wie eine Brille.
Sie auf die Forderungen eingehen von VZBV und Amnesty International an den AI
Act oder sagen wir einfach okay wir haben jetzt zweieinhalb Stunden oder so,
das nicht geschafft und wir geben jetzt auf.
Was wollen die denn?
Das bin ich auf Temperatur, was wollt ihr denn? Ihr wollt mir mein Chachipiti wegnehmen oder was?
Was fällt euch ein?
Also es gibt den AI-Act.
Also natürlich hat diese Technologie, also ganz einfach gesagt,
weil sie einen großen Datenbedarf hat, hat sie natürlich Datenschutzimplikationen.
Wir haben ja auch schon über die Diskussion zum Beispiel über Copyright gesprochen,
dass sich jetzt Künstlerinnen und Künstler darüber Gedanken machen,
wie sie verhindern können, dass ihre Bilder zum Training von solchen Modellen
genutzt werden und so weiter.
Das heißt, alle traditionellen Bereiche, die durch das Internet ins Wanken geraten
sind, Datenschutz, Urheberrecht, die schwellen natürlich jetzt auch wieder an.
Und dann natürlich noch dieses mit dem Entscheidungstreffen und so weiter.
Und mein Einstieg in das Thema Regulierung war ja dann auch mit dem,
was wenn man da jetzt Entscheidungen dran knotet und so weiter.
Jetzt will der spanische Ratsvorsitz mal wieder, genauso wie bei der Chat-Kontrolle,
die weiteren großen Fragen der AI-Verordnung klären und jetzt sagen wir mal
weniger, was die klären wollen, sondern womit Leute unzufrieden sind.
Ich zitiere aus einem Artikel von Lena Rohrbach, die ist bei Amnesty International
Referentin für Menschenrechte im digitalen Zeitalter und Rüstungsexportkontrolle.
Sie sagt also, Gesichtserkennung und andere inakzeptable Technologien sollen verboten werden.
Da geht es jetzt insbesondere natürlich auch im öffentlichen Raum und in der
sogenannten intelligenten Videotechnologie.
Da gibt es ja diese ganzen Diskussionen, wo Gesichtserkennung im Prinzip und
Überwachungsmethoden hier,
Verdacht auf Drogenhandel, in diesem ganzen Bereich, da soll also mindestens
Gesichtserkennung, wenn nicht auch dieses Predictive Policing,
eingedämmt werden, verhindert werden.
Dann KI-Einsatz durch Behörden darf kein Geheimnis sein. Da gibt es wirklich
ein ganz krasses Beispiel, dass in den Niederlanden haben wir tatsächlich irgendwann
mal durch einen Fehler 20.000.
Leute eine hohe Summe an Kindergeldrückzahlungen bekommen, weil die in irgendeinem
Algorithmus durchgedreht ist. Und das ist natürlich, also jetzt lachst du darüber,
aber wenn jetzt irgendwie, wenn eine Behörde dir schreibt, wir kriegen noch Geld von dir.
Und wenn da irgendein Algorithmus durchgedreht ist, dann hilft dir das auch nicht, ne?
Das heißt, KI-Einsatz durch Behörden darf kein Geheimnis sein,
muss also kontrolliert werden.
Und das wird gerade insbesondere an diesem Beispiel der niederländischen Steuerbehörde,
die den Leuten auf einmal Geld wieder wegnehmen wollte, klar gemacht. Aber Lust geht.
Drittens, kein Blankoschein für Missbrauch unter dem Deckmantel nationale Sicherheit.
Da wären wir im Prinzip nicht weit von dem, was gerade mit der Chat-Kontrolle
gemacht wird, oder versucht wird, dass also mit technologischen Heilsversprechen
Überwachungstechnologien ausgerollt werden sollen.
Dann soll, im AI-Act ist entscheidend, Hochrisiko-KI.
Und das muss natürlich klar definiert sein. Wann ist etwas mit hohem Risiko verbunden?
Und dann soll es stärker reguliert werden, um die Risiken noch stärker zu begrenzen.
Ein Beispiel wäre, ist jetzt diese Kindergeldnummer da in den Niederlanden,
ist das schon Hochrisikokategorie KI oder nicht?
Hier geht es also darum, die EU-Kommission hat dafür eine Definition vorgeschlagen,
aber da soll es halt keine Schlupflöcher drin geben, damit jetzt nicht irgendwelche
Start-ups benachteiligt sind oder große Unternehmen irgendwie.
Können. Also Hochrisiko-KI soll ohne Schlupfloch erstmal klar reguliert werden.
Und Grundrechtsfolgeabschätzungen sollen vorgenommen werden,
dass man also bei den Hochrisiko-KI-Systemen die Leute verpflichtet,
dass vernünftige Abschätzungen für Grundrechtseinschränkungen vorgenommen werden
und eben potenziell den Grundrechten mehr Vorrang gegeben wird vor dem Geld,
was die Leute mit ihrer KI verdienen wollen.
Das ist bitter, ja, das ist eine bittere Einschränkung, aber wird man hoffentlich mit klarkommen.
Der Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband konzentriert sich ein bisschen auf einer anderen Ebene.
Die sagen also erstens, haben die Betroffenen ein Recht auf Auskunft und Erklärung,
wenn sie also von Hochrisiko-KI betroffen sind und dann können sie sagen,
welche Daten werden hier verwendet? Wie ist diese Entscheidung zustande gekommen?
Ja, da muss man natürlich sagen, welche Daten verwendet sind,
wie die Entscheidung zustande gekommen ist. Wenn man jetzt hier Betroffene von
der High Ring KI von Amazon ist, ist das schwierig.
Aber ich denke, sicherlich ist es nicht falsch, hier ein Recht auf Beschwerde
und Transparenz zu haben.
Dann möchten Sie einen Schutz vor Manipulation und Ausnutzung persönlicher verschwächen.
Da geht es jetzt schon direkt in diesem Bereich. Wenn menschliches Verhalten
in Echtzeit analysiert wird, werden Menschen situativ verwundbar.
Beispielsweise könnte eine Person, die zu Spielsucht neigt, gestresst ist oder
so, von einer KI erkannt werden und dann darf das nicht ausgenutzt werden. Ja, ja.
Also ich meine, Spielsüchtige werden schon auch so durch das Aufstellen von
Spielautomaten für Spielsüchtige ausgenutzt.
Da sind wir also immer an so einer diffusen Grenze, wo ich immer auch ein bisschen,
weißt du, so ein bisschen die Angst vor der Maschine raushöre.
Während es aber natürlich ein Problem ist, wenn wir uns demnächst hier,
und das wird ja passieren, mit Hilfe solcher Technologien, wird man uns ja auch manipulieren.
Also Micro-Targeting on Steroids. Du hast es ja gerade selber gesagt,
dass das eines der größten Risiken für die Gesellschaft gerade ist.
Und als letztes jetzt vor ZBV. Sie sagen, man muss natürlich auch eine effektive
Rechtsdurchsetzung sicherstellen und dafür wollen Sie die Verbandsklage für
den Missbrauch von KI ermöglichen.
Beziehungsweise gegen den Missbrauch von KI, sodass Einzelbetroffene nicht alle
einzeln den Rechtsweg gehen müssen,
sondern eben Verbände direkt, also Institutionen,
beispielsweise VZBV, deswegen will er das natürlich auch haben,
Klagen gegen bestimmte KI-Betreibende im Namen der geschädigten Verbraucherin
durchzuführen und Entschädigungen einzufordern, dass sie da ein starkes Regulativ-Hass.
Das sind jetzt so die Themen, mit denen sich gerade, sagen wir mal,
aus eher techfernen Dimensionen stammende Organisationen, also Amnesty International
hat einen sehr viel weiteren Arbeits- und Einflussbereich als AI,
der Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband natürlich auch.
Das sind so die Gedanken, die sich gerade über diese Technologie machen.
Also, alles, was ich da jetzt gehört habe...
Meiner Meinung nach alles überhaupt gar keine KI spezifischen Fragestellungen.
Also ob nun irgendein komplexer Algorithmus oder etwas, was tatsächlich auf
Machine Learning basiert, hier in irgendeiner Form zu den befürchteten Auswirkungen
führt, ist am Ende meiner Auffassung nach ziemlich Wurst.
Also gerade wenn du jetzt anfängst zu sagen ja das ist aber jetzt hier für KI,
dann können ja Leute auch immer noch sagen so ja gut aber unser System ist ja gar nicht KI,
wir haben ja noch einen komplexen Statistik basierten Suchalgorithmus,
KI ist da hinten um die Ecke.
Ich bin mir noch nicht mal so, also da werde ich jetzt mal von ausgehen,
dass das relativ einfach gelöst wird, das Problem, in dem du sagst halt was
weiß ich, algorithmische oder maschinelle Entscheidung, ne und dann hast du das Thema gelöst.
Also ich kann verstehen, dass es da ein Definitionsproblem gibt,
ich würde aber davon ausgehen, dass das den Autorinnen des Proposals auch klar
ist und die halt schon, Darin sind JuristInnen gut, deswegen schreiben die ja
die Gesetze, um stichhaltige Definitionen zu formulieren.
Ja gut, aber das bedeutet ja auch, dass du das scharfkantig technisch festmachen kannst.
Wie gesagt, ich sage ja nicht, dass die genannten Auswirkungen nicht unter Umständen
wirklich beklagenswert sind, nur die jetzt unter dem Titel KI zu führen,
obwohl all diese Probleme auch ohne KI auftreten können.
Da ist ja nix KI spezifisches dabei halte ich erstmal für einen komischen Ansatz
also warum ist das jetzt auf einmal ein Problem und vorher nicht schon.
Na gut das ist, ok war es wahrscheinlich vorher auch im AI Act soll, AI Act heißt ja nun mal.
Ja gut, aber das, wie gesagt, da bin ich mir eben nicht so sicher,
ob wir eigentlich schon das bewerten können, was wir AI spezifisch wirklich
zu regeln haben oder wir nicht generell vor Schutz sprengen.
Ich meine, wenn wir über sowas reden wie Gesichtserkennung in der Öffentlichkeit,
dass die Technologie heutzutage primär auf Machine Learning basiert,
ja okay gut, aber die könnte...
Das hat sich auf was anderem basiert und auch schon so ein bisschen funktioniert.
Da war das aber auch schon eine schlechte Idee. Also das Problem ist,
die Anwendung in der Öffentlichkeit auf Leute, die sich dagegen nicht wehren
können, die nicht beobachtet werden wollen, nicht so sehr die Technologie,
die da drauf gelegt wird.
Natürlich macht jetzt AI alles wieder billiger.
Das ist ja auch generell dieses Problem, was wir immer mit Überwachung haben.
Überwachung wird in dem Moment immer interessant, wo es bezahlbar wird.
Niemand kam in den 80er Jahren darauf, riesige Überwachungsprogramme zu starten.
Erst als sie billig wurden, dann kam das Thema auf.
Und natürlich erleben wir jetzt durch AI eine Kostenreduktion in einem exorbitanten
Maße für Dinge, die vorher nur mit sehr, sehr, sehr viel Aufwand,
aber eben nicht nicht gemacht werden konnten.
Und ich finde es richtig, dass man sich über die Auswirkungen von Computern
auf die Gesellschaft nach wie vor Gedanken macht und solche Auswirkungen dann auch verbietet.
Ich bezweifle nur, dass jetzt sozusagen das Stichwort AI da das richtige ist.
Klar, das ist so ein Faktor, aber keine Ahnung, irgendwie wird uns das glaube
ich später, also auch wenn das, ich auch gerade von mir selber so als so eine
Revolution jetzt dargestellt wurde, was es auch ist, ist es am Ende auch nur
ein fließender Übergang.
Und die Auswirkungen sind letzten Endes relevant und nicht die Technologie,
die das dann konkret ermöglicht.
Also und das ist ja erstmal nicht schlecht, dass sich da generell drum gekümmert wird.
Ja ja klar, das wäre wahrscheinlich schlimmer, wenn die jetzt sagen würden,
wir versuchen jetzt genau diese Technologie irgendwie zu behindern.
Also du hast jetzt, okay, das ist ja doch eigentlich ganz positiv.
Ich hatte ja mal hier, da warst du ja nicht dabei,
ich hab mal ein Interview oder eine Sendung gemacht,
mit Matthias Spielkamp, genau über Algorithm Watch und das ist ja im Prinzip genau das Projekt,
die sich schon immer mit diesen Auswirkungen beschäftigt haben,
das ist jetzt nicht AI Watch, sondern das ist halt wirklich Algorithm,
also das ist der Algorithmus, das was der Computer abarbeitet am Ende und auch
AI ist letzten Endes nur ein Algorithmus, auch wenn er sich nicht mehr so ohne
weiteres, leicht erklären lässt,
wie er zu den einzelnen Entscheidungen gekommen ist, nur so zu allen.
Genau, aber das lohnt sich auch nochmal dort reinzuhören.
Logbuch Netzpolitik 432.
Okay, wir sind jetzt am Ende dieses Themas.
Aber nur für diese Sendung.
In den Schaunachstand, wir können ja noch ein bisschen darüber reden.
Wir nähern uns der 3 Stunden Marke. Ja. Aber es gibt gute Nachrichten.
Für alle, die dem letzten Hype aufgesessen sind.
Eure NFTs, die sind ja wertlos, habt ihr gedacht, aber ihr könnt...
Erst habt ihr was anderes gedacht. Erst habt ihr gedacht, jetzt werde ich reich.
Ja, aber es gibt jetzt noch die Möglichkeit, dass ihr eure NFTs nochmal zu etwas Geldähnlichem macht.
Und zwar einem Einkaufsgutschein von einer großen Handelskette,
die wir jetzt nicht erwähnen, weil wir nicht werben für große Handelsketten,
zumindest nicht solange die nicht bezahlen.
Aber die geben euch einen 10 Euro Gutschein für euren NFT und die haben dafür,
also Also du musst dann irgendwie deinen NFT, deinen Einkaufsgutschein,
dann musst du dich irgendwie registrieren, dann musst du Teilnahmebedingungen
und so weiter machen, so viel tausend, dann kannst du deinen NFT dahin tun.
Und die haben dann eine Wall of Lame, wo sie die ganzen NFTs,
die sie ja jetzt quasi für 10 Euro Einkaufsgutschein abgreifen.
Die gehören natürlich dann eben diesem, ja was ist das eigentlich,
ein Land, ist ein Kaufland eigentlich, ein ganzes Land ist das.
Den gehören dann diese NFTs und dann verkaufen sie die wahrscheinlich nachher wieder.
Aber eine sehr schöne Werbeaktion, alle eingetauschten NFTs werden von uns innerhalb
von drei Werktagen manuell überprüft. Sobald dein NFT freigegeben wurde,
erhältst du von uns eine Bestätigung per E-Mail.
Deinen Einkaufsgutschein senden wir frühestens nach Ablauf des Kampagnenzeitraums
innerhalb von drei Werktagen per E-Mail zu.
Beachte dabei, dass wir dir nur einen Einkaufsgutschein bereitstellen,
auch wenn du mehrere NFTs einreichst.
Ja, aber da steht ja jetzt gar nicht, was mit dem NFT passiert.
Der gehört dann dem Unternehmen.
Der kommt auf die Webseite.
Ja, ja, also, es ist ein guter Witz.
Es ist nett, dass die sich da drum kümmern, da noch mal jemandem.
Ich meine, das sind Leute, die haben auch mitunter viel Geld verloren.
Und ich finde das in Ordnung, wenn die da jetzt mal so einfach einen Nahrungsmittelgutschein kriegen.
Aber nur einen pro Person.
Ja, reicht auch. Jeder nur einen Nahrungsmittelgutschein.
Alter, NFT.
Es ist ja dann doch aber, das Schöne ist ja, die NFT Nummer ist jetzt vermutlich durch.
Die ist durch. Die ist wirklich durch.
Aber zwischenzeitlich, Wenn da so eine Phase ist, wo die dann wieder alle ihre
Lieder vom NFT singen, dann denkst du irgendwann auch so, boah,
das kann doch nicht sein, ey, das ist doch Scheiße.
Du denkst dir halt die ganze Zeit, das kann doch nicht sein.
Und dann ist es eigentlich ganz schön, dass, wenn es dann, also es ist ein schöner Moment,
dann am Ende noch ein paar Kauflandgutscheine verteilt werden und das Thema
wirklich durch ist und du und du nicht mehr an der Realität zweifelst.
Tja, ich finde es gerade ganz angenehm und ich kann bei der Gelegenheit noch
mal so abschließend einen Vortrag von mir empfehlen, der noch nicht so viel
geschaut wurde. Mein NFT-Vortrag, kennst du meinen NFT-Vortrag?
Nee.
Den habe ich, der ist richtig gut,
den habe ich an der Universität für angewandte Kunst in Wien gehalten.
Der heißt, ist das DevRandom oder kann das nach DevNull Wert und Wertlosigkeit
von Kultur und Schaffen?
Das ist ja dann immer, das ist dann eine Uni, da muss das so ein bisschen,
da muss noch so ein Thema zum, da musste ich über Kunst und Archivierung sprechen bei einer Konferenz.
Es war wirklich, hat echt viel Spaß gemacht, war super lustig.
Und genau, NFT spielen da drin auch eine Rolle und überhaupt digitale Kunst
und so weiter. Genau. Andi Grote kommt auch drin vor.
Wer war das nochmal?
Das ist irgendein Spimmel.
Ach, der. Gut. Genug nft genug lnp.
Und es wirkt sich, man sieht mal wieder, je weniger wir die Sendung vorbereiten
desto länger wird die. Es ist wirklich Mark Twain at his best.
Ja ein bisschen vorbereitet haben wir die schon.
Entschuldigung für die lange Sendung, wir hatten keine Zeit eine kurze vorzubereiten.
So sieht's aus.
Alright, dann, wie sagen, sagen wir tschüss und wir hören uns nächste Woche wieder oder so.
So machen wir das.
Genau, bis bald. Ciao, ciao.